bon monsieur je vous propose que nous
commençons pour ne pas
compliquer ralentir les choses
que là il nous rejoindra
tous les bons merci de nous avoir
rejoint ce matin
on se retrouve pour une deuxième
séquence d'audition
dans le cadre de la mission sur la
simplification des normes
applicable aux entreprises
mission qui a été confiée à Gilbert Luc
de Vinas
Jean-Pierre moïga qui nous rejoint et
Olivier Rickman qui ne ce qui sera
absent
les auditions précédentes ont mis en
évidence plusieurs éléments la nécessité
d'un portage politique fort de la
simplification
c'est un sujet que vous connaissez
particulièrement bien la simplification
comme préalable à la numérisation qui ne
peut s'y substituer on a mis l'exemple
d'imaginer que la numérisation va
simplifier les choses mais il faut
d'abord simplifier
les procédures et les méthodes avant de
se lancer
l'énorme gisement de compétitivité pour
notre économie bien sûr l'éclatement de
la politique de simplification entre
plusieurs acteurs secrétaire général du
gouvernement direction
interministérielle de la transformation
publique Conseil d'État par le manque
etc
les carences en matière d'évaluation
explosent mais aussi les insuffisances
des études d'impact que constatent
régulièrement le Conseil d'État
ce dernier rédigé plusieurs rapports
dont un 2016 sous la coordination de
Monsieur Charles Touboul
que nous accueillons donc ce matin et
consacré à simplification à la qualité
du droit que j'ai là dans le cadre de la
section du rapport et des études dont
vous êtes président adjoint monsieur
Fabien Reynaud
une focalisation avec ce rapport sur les
entreprises et les normes les concernant
ces dernières semblent moins bien
traitées que les collectivités
territoriales qui disposent avec le
Conseil national d'évaluation des normes
d'un relais la situation est inverse en
Europe
il y a plus d'attention portée aux
entreprises qu'aux collectivités
nous sommes particulièrement heureux que
j'entende sur ce sujet vous remercions
d'être présent ce matin j'aurais été on
salue pourriez-vous nous indiquer quels
sont parmi les préconisations de votre
rapport de 2016 celle qui ont été
suivies celles qui ont au contraire
étaient négligées et pour quelle raison
que faudrait-il faire pour rendre la
réglementation concernant les
entreprises si ce n'est moins lourdes à
tout le moins plus efficace c'est-à-dire
adapté à la réalité économique
proportionnée à la taille des
entreprises
je cèlerai évidemment la parole pour un
propos liminaire d'une durée de 10
minutes chacun on en convient puis nos
deux rapporteurs présents donc super Luc
de Vidal et Jean-Pierre mogun que je
salue
[Musique]
auront quelques questions pour compléter
leur travaux
bon conseil technique de bien utiliser
les micros pour l'enregistrement
évidemment des interventions
[Musique]
et à l'issue de cette auditions je
rappellerai de bien vouloir renvoyer les
réponses aux questionnaire qui a été
adressé ça nous permet de compléter
le travail de secrétariat voilà je vous
remercie encore une fois je vous laisse
la parole sur un autre peut-être pour
démarrer une dizaine de minutes puis
ensuite les questions merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
sénateurs mesdames messieurs d'abord
cette audition et pour l'invitation à
cette audition
je commencerai peut-être par des propos
liminaires un peu plus généraux et puis
je céderai la parole à mon collègue
Charles togol sur l'étude de 2016 que
qu'évidemment il connaît beaucoup mieux
que moi puisque moi à l'époque je
n'étais pas
à la section du rapport et des études
bon évidemment c'est une c'est une étude
qui a été adoptée par l'Assemblée
Générale plénière donc qui engage
naturellement tout le Conseil d'État y
compris ceux qui comme moi était dans
d'autres fonctions notamment la section
du contentieux ce que je voulais
rappeler pour commencer de manière
générale vous le savez bien mais je
crois que c'est quand même utile de le
rappeler c'est que le Conseil d'État
s'intéresse depuis très longtemps à ces
questions de simplification des normes
et peut-être a-t-il été assez pionnier
dans le domaine puisque ça fait déjà
plus de 30 ans avec le rapport de 1991
qui avait été un rapport assez marquant
dans lequel il avait souligné le
problème de
l'inflation normative
et qui dans lequel il avait souligné les
risques que cette inflation normatif
faisait peser sur la cohésion sociale
puisque il avait des phrases assez
fortes sur le fait que les usagers
c'est-à-dire
les personnes mais évidemment aussi les
les entreprises
pouvaient se retrouver
l'inflation de la moitié pour y
provoquer la colère de l'usager censé ne
pas ignorer des règles qui lui devait
impossible de connaître compte tenu de
leur leur instabilité leur inflation etc
le Conseil d'État faisait déjà un
certain nombre de préconisations
notamment sur un effort sur un rapport
de faisabilité pour chaque loi sur les
nécessités de formation notamment de
formation juridique des fonctionnaires
et après ce rapport de 1991 il a eu à
plusieurs occasions
il a rappelé ce message à plusieurs
occasions notamment par le rapport
annuel de 2006 qui insistait là encore
sur cette question de la simplification
alors cette antériorité est à la fois
à mettre à l'actif du Conseil d'État et
peut-être aussi au passif parce que
force est de constater que malgré ces
rappels anciens et répétés la question
de la simplification demeure entière
comme le montre
l'étude que à laquelle procède votre
votre délégation alors c'est vrai que le
Conseil d'État avait déjà remarqué
souligné dans ces études notamment dans
cette de 1991 que la difficulté de
l'inflation normative de la complexité
des normes était d'abord quelque chose
de très ancien il y avait en relisant
les rapports il y avait une citation de
Montaigne lui-même qui disait que je les
cite nous avons en France plus de lois
que le reste du monde ensemble alors je
sais pas comment Montaigne avait fait
son calcul à l'époque probablement que
c'était assez au doigt mouillé on
reviendra à ces questions de calcul mais
il y avait déjà un problème français
récurrent et le Conseil d'État souligne
dans ces différents études que cette
complexité cette inflation normative
elle répond à des causes très profondes
je crois qu'il faut avoir sa présence à
l'esprit parce que ça a une influence
naturellement sur les remèdes que l'on
peut envisager pour répondre à ces
difficultés
et c'est cause très profond c'est la
culture du droit écrit dans notre pays
la force symbolique de la norme et
notamment de la loi
le poids politique
vous le savez bien monsieur
revêt le texte qui a tendance dans notre
pays à être un peu performatif il suffit
d'adopter le texte pour qu'on considère
que voilà
alors ce qui amène le Conseil d'État à
l'heure actuelle dans l'étude que nous
sommes en train de mener que dont vous
avez peut-être connaissance qui porte
sur le dernier kilomètre des politiques
publiques alors le terme est évolutif
parce que mais l'idée c'est de
s'attaquer aux problèmes de la
simplification
par j'allais dire une autre face enfin
une autre logique qui est par rapport à
nos précédentes études qui est de partir
de l'usager
et de s'interroger et de s'intéresser du
point de vue de l'usager donc en ren la
logique habituelle pour essayer de voir
dans quelle mesure il est
atteint par les politiques publiques et
dans quelle mesure ça fonctionne ou ça
ne fonctionne pas quels sont les bons
exemples quels sont les mauvaises
exemples etc donc ça c'est un travail en
cours sur lequel nous permettrait d'être
assez prudent encore parce que nous
sommes dans le travail d'audition mais
je crois que c'est intéressant par
rapport à cette problématique de la
simplification parce que c'est un effort
d'essayer au fond peut-être de se dire
que bon nous avons fait plusieurs
rapports il y a un certain nombre de
recommandations qui ont été suivies on
va y revenir à propos de l'étude de 2007
d'autres qui n'ont pas été mais le
problème peut-être ne reste-t-il pas
entier peut-être qu'il a quand même été
en partie mais en tout cas le problème
demeure donc essayons de l'aborder
autrement la dernière chose que je
voudrais dire
et là qui est j'allais dire plus
personnel
et avant de céder la parole à Charles
tout boule c'est que moi je crois
beaucoup
dans ces questions de simplification à
une approche consistant à dire sur qui
fait-on reprocher fait-on
porter reposer le poids de la complexité
parce que vous l'avez dit on
introduction l'idée de réduire la masse
des normes n'est quand même pas tout à
fait simple nous sommes des sociétés
complexes on voit bien que
l'idéal la vision peut-être irénique de
d'un droit qui est tout d'un coup qu'on
arriverait tout d'un coup à réduire
beaucoup pareil quand même assez
difficilement enfin assez peu réaliste
en tout cas à mes yeux assez peu
réalistes la question c'est comment sur
qui pèse cette complexité et je crois
que c'est une des clés d'entrée sur le
sujet et il me semble que il faut tendre
vers une situation dans laquelle la
complexité ne repose pas sur l'usager
justement que ce soit les entreprises ou
les les
personnes privées mais repose davantage
sur les experts c'est-à-dire
l'administration le juge etc alors nous
avons essayé de le faire j'en terminerai
par là pour vous citer un exemple
concret tout récent une décision du
Conseil d'État statut en contentieux la
décision de section du 9 décembre 2022
commune de Saint-Herblain dans le par
laquelle nous avons jugé en renversant
une jurisprudence qui était plus
ancienne que lorsque une commune
réclame à un pétitionnaire de quelqu'un
qui réclame une autorisation d'urbanisme
pour faire large parce que
lorsque la commune lui demande de
produire des pièces supplémentaires
alors même que ces pièces
supplémentaires ne sont pas dans la
liste exhaustive défini par le Code de
l'Urbanisme et bien cette demande n'a
pas pour effet d'interrompre le délai
qui fait naître une décision tacite
d'acceptation donc ça permet finalement
aux pétitionnaires de se retrouver dans
une situation qui est plus simple plus
claire
il sait dès lors que il a présenté un
dossier qui comporte tous les éléments
qui sont exigés par le code que à
l'issue du délai d'instruction naîtra
une décision favorable alors évidemment
ça fait reposer des difficultés sur les
services instructeurs parce que parfois
on se demande est-ce qu'on a besoin de
telle ou tel élément mais je crois que
c'est un exemple dans lequel il y a un
effort pour faire reposer la complexité
sur le petit itionnait sur
l'administration plutôt que sur le
pétitionnaire et je sais tout de suite
la parole si vous m'y autorisez monsieur
le Président au rapporteur général
adjoint de l'étude de 2016 et donc à la
cheville ouvrière de l'étude de 2016 qui
va plus précisément
reparler de cette étude et vous donner
les vues que qu'il a en tant que
rapporteur général adjoint et puis avec
l'expérience administrative qui est la
sienne depuis
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur les corateurs mesdames et
messieurs merci beaucoup d'abord pour
cette invitation qui effectivement nous
a fait très plaisir et Fabien Reynaud
version des sujets qui nous intéressent
beaucoup et
comme actuellement membre de la SCE et
ancien membre de la Sree donc la section
du rapport et des études du Conseil
d'État on a vraiment à cœur
d'assurer le si j'ose dire le service
après-vente le suivi des études qui sont
faites par le Conseil d'État et d'être
je sais pas si c'est le dernier
kilomètre mais en tout cas d'être dans
l'effectivité des choses voir l'impact
réel de ce qu'on a pu proposer
effectivement j'étais le rapporteur
général adjoint de l'étude 2016
c'était Patrick Gérard qui était le
rapporteur général et qui donc
supervisait les travaux et qui avec moi
suivaient et a suivi depuis beaucoup ces
sujets de simplification alors peut-être
quelques mots sur un peu sur la genèse
famille Raynaud on a parlé mais sur la
jeunesse de l'étude 2016 pour vous
livrer aussi un sentiment assez
personnel c'est vraiment poser la
question de savoir s'il fallait une
étude de plus sur la simplification je
permet d'évoquer cette question ici
parce que je suis à peu près certain que
vous voulez poser également pour ce qui
vous concerne et j'imagine qu'on est
passé par le même cheminement une étude
de plus pourquoi faire et en même temps
on ne peut absolument pas se résigner à
la situation actuelle et c'est
finalement le cheminement du Conseil
d'État en 2016 et peut-être que ce sera
le vôtre cette année et je crois
qu'effectivement il faut pas se il faut
pas se résigner dans les réflexions
préalables l'étude de 2016 il y avait
donc ce souci d'apporter quelque chose
d'utile quelque chose de concret et ce
qu'on s'est dit au Conseil d'État c'est
que sur la simplification des normes
d'énormes en général et d'énormes pour
les entreprises en particulier le
Conseil d'État je pense que c'est assez
vrai aussi pour une assemblée
parlementaire conseil état n'était pas
le plus mal placé pour faire des
préconisations et aussi c'est très
important et c'était assez novateur en
2016 pour le Conseil d'État se fixer des
objectifs à lui-même prendre des
engagements publics et ensuite
évidemment
veiller à les mettre en oeuvre alors je
vais y venir à certains nombre de
propositions ont été faites toutes n'ont
pas été concrétisées mais je tiens à
dire que celles qui reposait directement
sur le rôle du Conseil d'État sur ce que
le Conseil d'État pouvait faire lui-même
c'est propositions là ce qu'on a appelé
donc des engagements puisqu'on se
proposait à nous-mêmes de faire des
choses ces engagements ils ont été tenus
alors un premier engagement qui était
vraiment très très cher à notre cœur
quand on a fait cette étude c'était
celui d'objectiver les choses parce que
vous le savez en matière de
simplification on parle de beaucoup de
phénomènes différents et qui n'ont pas
forcément grand chose à voir les uns
avec les autres est-ce que le problème
c'est le quantité c'est la quantité de
norme est-ce que le problème c'est la
complexité intrinsèque de la norme
est-ce que le problème c'est
l'instabilité de la norme est-ce que le
problème c'est le ressenti sur la norme
tout ça évidemment
tous ces éléments entretiennent des
relations les uns avec les autres et en
même temps chaque élément est un peu
différent de l'autre donc on a cherché
vraiment objectiver les choses et dans
ce travail d'objectivation le premier
point qui est venu c'est c'était
peut-être le plus simple et en même
temps il n'était pas fait en 2016
c'était la mesure quantitative de la
norme de quoi parle-t-on c'est quoi le
stock des normes c'est quoi le flux des
normes en quantité sans même se poser la
question de la charge que ça représente
qui est une question beaucoup plus
délicate mais juste en termes de
quantité mesurer cette fameuse inflation
normative
on a dans l'étude 2016 reposer
clairement la question on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait eu des tentatives
quelques années précédentes d'objectiver
donc de mesurer les choses qui n'avaient
pas été pérennisé et la première
proposition qui a été faite dans l'étude
2016 c'est-à-dire il faut que le
gouvernement se mette en situation de
mesurer la production normatique d'un
point de vue purement quantitatif et
cette préconisation qu'on ne pouvait pas
mener complètement jusqu'à son terme
dans le cadre de l'étude elle-même parce
qu'elle était très macro on abordait
beaucoup de sujets elle a elle a fait un
petit si j'ose dire il y a eu une petite
étude dédiée en 2018 dont j'étais le
rapporteur également sur mesurer
l'inflation normative et on a travaillé
étroitement avec le secrétariat général
du gouvernement pour voir comment
mesurait les choses voilà quel était le
critère pertinent sur des choses
extrêmement triviales est-ce qu'on
compte en nombre de lois ou de décrets
est-ce qu'on compte en nombre de pages
de Jo est-ce qu'on compte en nombre de
mots voilà ce sont des questions qui
peuvent paraître pas très ambitieuses et
qui en même temps sont essentiels pour
avoir une mesure un peu fiable des
choses donc c'est une première
réalisation
puisqu'à la suite donc de l'étude 2016
qui vraiment disait il faut faire cette
mesure quantitative
l'étude 2018 qui a permis de bâtir le
corpus méthodologique pour le faire on a
depuis plusieurs années parce que c'est
un énorme travail et je salue les
efforts du scratoria général du
gouvernement qui le fait rigoureusement
chaque année on a donc depuis lors une
photo annuelle faite par le Secrétariat
général du gouvernement de manière
extrêmement fine de la production
normative secteur par secteur et vecteur
par vecteur et avec les différentes
unités de mesure que j'évoquais donc
voilà c'est certainement pas la réponse
à tous les mots c'est néanmoins un
préalable et ce préalable maintenant il
existe et il faut il faut s'en nourrir
alors je j'évoque un point connexe parce
que il faisait partie des éléments que
vous pointiez dans les documents de
réflexion préalables à cette audition
que vous nous avez communiqué et
notamment le questionnaire sur comment
on mesure la charge administrative donc
là on est plus dans le quantitatif on
est davantage dans le qualitatif alors
sur la charge administrative et
notamment la déception que vous exprimez
ou que vous ressentez et qu'on partage
au Conseil d'État sur le fait qu'on
pourrait être peut-être meilleur et pour
être meilleur peut-être devrait-on avoir
de meilleurs outils de mesure de cette
charge administrative
on n'a pas pu faire le même travail au
Conseil d'État en toute franchise c'est
aussi parce qu'on est plus loin de nos
bases voilà c'est plus du droit mesurer
l'impact économique social
environnemental des choses voilà on sait
faire on contrôleur on n'est pas des
faiseurs au Conseil d'État donc on était
un petit peu moins armés pour faire des
préconisations cela étant des travaux
ont été menés également parce que
derrière général du gouvernement et il y
a notamment sur les gifrance
deux outils à la disposition des
administrations centrales puisque ce
sont elles qui rédigent les études
d'impact en premier lieu avant qu'elle
soit contrôlées sur justement la manière
de dévaluer la charge qui s'attache à
une norme c'est le temps que mais une
entreprise ou un usager pour d'abord
découvrir d'abord accéder à la norme
ensuite la lire la comprendre ensuite
mettre en oeuvre une obligation
déclarative type mettre en oeuvre une
obligation de
demander une autorisation préalable ou
faire ce qu'on appelle en bon français
du reporting à l'administration enfin
bref vraiment un effort de
comment dire
d'identifier les différentes tâches qui
peuvent peser sur les usagers individus
ou entreprise ou collectivités locales
je leur dirai un mot et essayer de
quantifier le temps que ça peut prendre
à chacun pour faire donc ce travail là
il existe il a été fait ça permet de
cadrer un peu les travaux d'études
d'impact donc on a un corpus j'ai envie
de dire administrative aux scientifique
pour objectiver ce travail et faire en
sorte qu'il soit mené de manière
sérieuse
comme vous le savez sur les études
d'impact je me permets d'en parler
librement même si je suis dans
l'administration centrale aujourd'hui
mais c'est aussi parce que j'enseigne la
matière depuis 10 ans les études
d'impact l'un des problèmes c'est les
outils de mesure
mais comme je viens de vous l'indiquer
ça je crois que c'est largement réglé
l'autre problème beaucoup plus
fondamental c'est que les études
d'impact elles sont très souvent
rédigées pour les besoins de la cause
une fois qu'on a pris la décision
politique de faire une loi
et donc il y a évidemment une voilà un
problème de crédibilité des études mais
qui est extrêmement profond et qui est
un problème je crois extrêmement
politique
de la même manière mais là je parle avec
encore plus de prudence pour ce qui
concerne une assemblée parlementaire à
quel point les études d'impact vous sont
utiles
compte tenu de la manière dont elles
sont faites et dont elles ont été
conçues y compris par le constituant une
étude d'impact voilà ça sert à instruire
les travaux au tout début de l'ex amen
d'un projet de texte
mais on sait que dès le premier
amendement adopté l'étude d'impact est
peut-être pas caduque mais elle est
périmée voilà et c'est évidemment un
élément qui pèse lourd dans
l'exploitation qu'on peut en faire et si
j'ose dire aussi dans la motivation des
administrations en produits puisque tout
ça est fait je me permets d'aller
jusqu'à la caricature et fait un peu
pour les besoins de la cause donc une
fois quand elles sont rédigées on sait
déjà que la décision sera prise d'y
aller et une fois que l'étude est faite
et bien on sait que voilà elle sera
regardée avec intérêt par les
commissions parlementaires et j'espère
que ça les aide pour faire le rapport
même si elles n'ont pas besoin de ça je
sais qu'elles sont exploitées au moins
par les commissions
en tout cas la Commission de la première
assemblée saisie ensuite on sait très
bien que ces études servent à pas grand
chose et évidemment c'est ça à mon sens
mais je pense que vous partagez ce
diagnostic le principal problème ça les
études d'impact beaucoup plus que que la
manière plus ou moins scientifique de
les nourrir pardon j'ai été beaucoup
trop long à un point qui me paraît
essentiel pour vos travaux juste pour
l'annoncer et je répondrai à vos
questions si vous en avez lorsque
l'étude 2016 a été faite donc on a
commencé à travailler en 2015 on était
dans déjà la sortie si j'ose dire du
comité impact entreprise de ce qui avait
été créé des organismes qui avaient été
créés pour mesurer spécifiquement la
charge des normes pour les entreprises
comité qui comme vous le savez a été
sans lendemain il n'a pas été prolongé
on avait déjà un peu conscience de ça la
décision était pas clairement prise au
moment où on travaillait mais on l'a on
la sentait venir et donc on a avait
proposé quelque chose pour le coup
d'assez significatif dans le rapport de
2016 qui était de faire vivre un comité
impact entreprises tel qu'il existait
mais dans un cadre plus général qui
était en fait directement inspiré de
celui du CNN que vous connaissez bien au
Sénat même si les suivis encore plus par
une autre délégation et cette idée de
créer donc un comité qui permettrait aux
destinataires des normes aux principaux
destinataires des normes collectivités
territoriales en premier lieu entreprise
en deuxième il y a pas d'ordinateurs en
deuxième lieu et usager en 3e lieu de se
prononcer sur l'impact des normes qui
étaient dans les tuyaux voilà que le
gouvernement se proposait de prendre
lui-même ou de proposer au Parlement
cette proposition je crois qu'elle
tourne elle tourne toujours il
n'appartenait pas au Conseil d'État de
faire autre chose que de la proposer
après c'était un choix politique ce que
je constate quelques années après c'est
que il y a eu sans doute voilà ou des
réserves ou d'autres priorités que cette
proposition n'a pas été n'a pas été mise
en oeuvre par le pouvoir politique mais
c'est évidemment son droit le plus
strict le Conseil d'État
particulièrement à la session du rapport
et des études fait des propositions et
après il appartient au pouvoir politique
de s'en saisir ou pas
pardon d'avoir été un petit peu lourd
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup de
ce premier éclairage chacun d'entre vous
je vais passer la parole évidemment au
rapporteur donc
tout d'abord j'aime bien Luc de vinasse
quelques questions merci merci de nous
accorder du temps
j'ai peut-être pas beaucoup de questions
mais cela dit le rapport du Conseil
d'État
qui a été rédigé en 2016 il proposait
définir une méthode de calcul de la
charge administrative et des autres
coups induits pour toute nouvelle norme
alors la question en 2022 c'est pourquoi
on n'y est pas arrivé
est-ce que c'est impossible en France
alors qu'on voit qu'en Allemagne voir au
niveau européen ils arrivent à le faire
ou je formule ma question plus
brutalement qu'est-ce qui bloque dans
notre pays
et pourquoi on bloque comment on peut
débloquer parce que j'ai l'impression
que
vous entendre et entendent de dernière
intervenant la partition elle est écrite
mais pourquoi on joue pas la musique
voilà c'est une première question je la
formule comme ça il y a un deuxième
sujet qui était abordé par Monsieur
Touboul effectivement
quand je me suis mis à être apporteur
d'un sujet où je m'étais jamais
intéressé ma première question c'est de
dire mais c'est quoi une norme
et et les normes ont différentes
origines il y a celles qui découlent de
ce que nous on peut voter à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat mais il y a
d'autres normes les normes ISO Etc mais
quand on est dans une entreprise tout ça
c'est une norme donc à partir du moment
où elles ont des origines différentes il
me semble que si on veut les simplifier
il faut aussi aller à la source si elles
ont des sources différentes ça va
impliquer et il y a vraisemblablement
des sources où il est plus difficile
pour le législateur de
s'attaquer une simplification par contre
celle qui viennent de qui découvrent de
nos lois on devrait y arriver après
monsieur Raynaud vous avez apporté en
disant on va changer de méthode et on va
apporter par l'usager
alors on a auditionné
d'autres structures qui qui vont dans ce
sens là
je vais prendre le guichet unique
et on a bien entendu les difficultés
deviennent pays mais moi dans la semaine
quand j'ai été à la Chambre du Commerce
et des métiers de mon territoire j'ai eu
une autre sorte de musique et la
question c'est est-ce que vous croyez
aujourd'hui quand on a fait le guichet
unique on est bien parti de la façon
dont on pouvait percevoir l'usager c'est
à dire en l'occurrence ceux qui
voulaient ou qui ont une entreprise
voilà merci
[Musique]
on va commencer sur le sur le premier
point je me permets d'apporter une
précision comme je l'iniquais il y a il
y a un référentiel qui a été fait
on avait fait en 2016 dans le cadre de
l'étude du Conseil d'État des
comparaisons internationales ont été
allé en Allemagne on a envoyé une
mission au Pays-Bas au Royaume-Uni
on a eu on a récolté des choses
intéressantes et comparaisons sont
malgré tout délicates à faire
on a essayé également de s'inspirer de
ce qui se faisait au niveau de l'OCDE au
niveau de la Commission européenne
chacun cherche un peu la martingale en
fait en termes d'évaluation et de mesure
de la charge des normes
et ce qui est proposé aux
administrations je le réaffichais
mon ordinateur
et quand même alors ça paraît peut-être
pas très sophistiqué mais ça permet
quand même de rentrer dans le concret et
de mesurer vraiment la charge qui
s'attache à une norme je voyais donc il
y a une rubrique durée des tâches
administratives donc ce familiariser
avec une obligation d'information et
vous avez trois colonnes facile 3
minutes modérée 15 minutes complexe 120
minutes tout ça ensuite est prolongé sur
les coûts salariaux donc vous avez le
coût fonctionnel en fonction du temps
qu'il passe à faire des tâches le coût
entreprise évidemment selon qu'il est
cadre employé ouvrier professionnels
comme je vous le disais c'est pas le
l'amitié du Conseil d'État et je parle
de cela avec beaucoup d'humilité et je
n'ai aucune responsabilité donc ce qui
est dans ce document c'est aussi pour ça
que je me permets de lui porter une
appréciation moi je le trouve plutôt
bien fait et
là aussi enfin c'est on en parle souvent
avec Fabien Raynaud la complexité il
faut évidemment
pas qu'elle pèse sur l'usager il faut
donc elle pèse sur l'administration
en même temps il faut pas non plus
qu'elle pèse à ce point sur
l'administration on la décourage
complètement de jouer le jeu et je
voyais ce document qui fait voilà une
cette page et je crois que c'est très
raisonnable si on veut que les
administrations sont saisissent et
l'utilisent peut-être que si on avait
fait quelque chose comme nos amis
allemands ou britanniques ou comme la
Commission européenne à faire voilà une
somme théologique sur le sujet peut-être
beaucoup plus ambitieuse
intellectuellement on n'aurait pas la
même efficacité et on aurait des
administrations qui n'ouvriraient
probablement pas le document et ne
ferait pas le jeu de la quant
sur ce premier point voilà je voulais
juste apporter cette ce petit éclairage
mais donc ça existe il y a d'autres
éléments qui existent alors encore je
suis un petit peu loin de mes bases mais
comme c'était des points d'interrogation
de votre part j'avais fait quelques
recherches avant l'audition sur le dit
le nous une fois vous demandiez ce que
c'était devenu et en faisant une petite
recherche j'ai retrouvé des éléments
assez récents qui ont un an ou deux ou
on voit que notamment la direction
interministérielle du numérique
a fait des propositions pour avancer sur
ces sujets là il y a tous les ans de
nouvelles démarches qui sont intégrés
dans le périmètre du dites le nous une
fois je voyais un bilan alors c'est vrai
que ça remonte maintenant à deux ans
c'était fin 2020 il y avait 35 nouvelles
démarches qui étaient intégrée dans le
dite le nous une fois voilà il y a
peut-être pas eu beaucoup de
communications publiques sur ce sujet
mais voilà l'administration essaie
d'avancer sur ces différents champs
elle essaye de
d'améliorer la vie des gens au quotidien
même si on est encore sans doute loin du
compte
essentiellement sur sur ces points là
sur le guichet unique j'avoue que j'ai
peu d'éléments donc je me laisse ça je
vous laisserai lâchement complété et sur
le
le fait de raisonner depuis l'usager
d'une manière générale ça je crois que
c'est vraiment maintenant intégré à peu
près partout moi ce que je crois
beaucoup c'est qu'il faut que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités et
ça se traîne à la simplification
et c'est pas si compliqué de faire
dans mes nouvelles fonctions alors je
suis au Strateur général de la défense
et de la sécurité nationale
j'ai une fonction normative qui est
relativement modeste
mais j'ai néanmoins des textes
législatifs et réglementaires qui
relèvent de mon périmètre
j'ai eu très récemment l'occasion de me
poser la question de savoir si voilà
pour améliorer un dispositif et ce qu'on
faisait du texte ou pas et alors
peut-être parce que je suis très
imprégné par la question de
simplification et que j'ai eu l'occasion
de le faire je me dis bah on va vraiment
essayer de faire sans texte pour une
fois mais c'est un vrai fort surtout
quand on est conseillé d'État
le réflexe parce ce qui est facile à
faire c'est le texte là ça on sait faire
ça prend quelques heures un peu plus
après quand il faut le faire cheminer
mais
c'est relativement aisé et puis on se
dit que ça va donner une impulsion que
ça va permettre de faire avancer les
choses parce qu'on a changé les règles
la vérité c'est que comme le rappelait
Fabien Raynaud en site en Montaigne
voilà beaucoup de gens ne regardent plus
la norme depuis longtemps que ce soit
des entreprises ou des usagers la norme
est très lointaine on s'en préoccupe
plus vraiment et donc la changer n'a pas
d'impact
changer les pratiques changer les choses
parfois changer une circulaire
changer un message une communication
publique changer une page de site
internet faire passer d'autres d'autres
idées par les administrations celles qui
sont en contact du public ça c'est
beaucoup plus difficile à faire mais
c'est en même temps beaucoup plus
efficace et on arrive à le faire sans
norme voilà donc y compris dans mes
nouvelles fonctions j'essaie de le faire
vivre j'essaie également de le faire
vivre dans mes activités ce sont juste
des illustrations un peu personnelles
mais je pense qu'on peut les prolonger
de manière plus générale j'ai des
activités d'enseignement et je sais que
ça fait partie de vos points de
préoccupation qu'est-ce qu'on dit aux
apprentis fonctionnaires qu'est-ce qu'on
dit dans les écoles de formation on va
j'enseigne depuis une petite quinzaine
d'années à l'ENA devenu issp et on a mis
en place une séance dédiée à la
simplification
pour les
usagers pour les entreprises et on
essaie d'expliquer que d'abord la
première chose à faire c'est faire moins
de normes et quand on en fait d'en faire
des plus simples et puis d'écouter les
usagers sur la manière dont elle peut
être donc là aussi c'est quelque chose
qui relève de ma pratique
professionnelle quotidienne et que
j'essaie de faire vivre et je crois
vraiment que
la clé
n'est pas dans un grand soir de la
simplification je crois que ça a été
tenté 1000 fois et personne n'y est
jamais vraiment parvenu en revanche que
chaque et je dis chacun c'est surtout
ceux qui ont une parcelle de la
responsabilité de ce champ c'est
évidemment le Conseil d'État c'est
évidemment les administrations centrales
où je suis aujourd'hui c'est évidemment
les assemblées parlementaires chacun
peut se fixer des engagements
peut prendre des bonnes résolutions pour
simplifier la vie des gens alors on en a
parlé dans d'autres délégations
notamment collectivités territoriales il
y a peu de temps ça peut être un
engagement de faire moins de projets de
loi moins de décrets c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire en ce moment et GDSN
peut-être moins d'amendement je lance
l'idée comme ça d'un point de vue
purement technique je porte pas le
jugement de valeur
mais voilà sans faire de grands plans
simplement en se disant pour ce qui
relève directement de ma responsabilité
à moi
je m'astreins enfin je m'engage à faire
ceci et cela en matière simplification
voilà je crois que c'est déjà chacun
faisait tout ça on aurait beaucoup
progressé dans la matière
alors peut-être en complément de de ce
que vient de dire Charles Touboul sur
les sur les trois questions que vous
avez posées monsieur le rapporteur
pourquoi est-ce que ça fonctionne pas
alors c'est vrai que c'est une question
assez redoutable parce que on voit bien
que voilà on fait des efforts on produit
des rapports
et on a l'impression que on est toujours
face au même difficulté moi ce que je
voudrais dire je voudrais dire deux
choses par rapport à cette question
la première c'est que
ça
on a du mal à mettre tout ça en musique
parce que en réalité c'est complexe
c'est c'est aussi la première à mon avis
cause de ça c'est la complexité et je
prends une illustration
il y a quelques années j'avais présidé
un groupe de travail au Conseil d'État
sur la transposition des directives et
on partait d'idée que
on surtransposé et qu'il fallait arrêter
de sur transposer et que il fallait
faire comme les qui transposait
systématiquement à minima donc là
j'allais dire enfin je vais pas
paraphraser le général de Gaulle mais
vers l'Orient compliqué avec des idées
simples mais c'est vrai que ça
paraissait simple on s'est dit ça alors
là on tient une bonne piste là on va et
en réalité quand on a creusé le sujet
quand on a auditionné
les différents notamment les
représentants des entreprises on s'est
rendu compte que c'était beaucoup plus
complexe
parce que quand il y a différents types
de surtances positions je prends un
exemple concret quand vous avez un
régime juridique qui en France était
unifiée
et que ce régime juridique est
partiellement modifié par une une
directive européenne et bien on est
confronté à la difficulté soit de
transposer à minima et à ce moment-là de
désunifier le régime juridique français
ou alors détendre le dispositif de la
directive
au-delà de ce qu'elle
exige au sens strict mais pour garder
l'unité du régime juridique en cause
et ça cet exemple on le retrouve dans de
nombreux dans de nombreuses
configurations outre le fait que
généralement
au niveau européen moi j'ai été dans les
affaires européennes pendant une
quinzaine d'années donc j'ai bien
pratiqué ça la France
contrairement à la Grande-Bretagne quand
elle était membre et généralement
demandeuse de de réglementation
européenne et demandeuse de
réglementation européenne ambitieuse
entre guillemets donc réglementante si
j'ose dire généralement c'est quand même
un peu c'est quand même un peu ça et le
deuxième la deuxième cause moi que
j'identifie
et on le retrouve beaucoup dans notre
étude actuelle sur le dernier kilomètre
et et c'est d'ailleurs pas tout à fait
rassurant parce que c'est une cause
assez systémique c'est le problème de la
confiance
c'est à dire que on est un pays dans
lequel le degré de confiance des
vis-à-vis des autres est assez faible et
du coup on veut tout écrire tout
réglementé tout écrire donc je crois que
c'est aussi une des difficultés à
laquelle on est confronté pour mettre en
oeuvre de manière concrète quelque chose
qui laisse plus de marge aux acteurs en
règlement en moi mais ça ça veut dire se
faire confiance
ensuite vous avez vous avez soulevé la
question de qu'est-ce qu'une norme et
c'est vrai que je trouve que c'est une
question qui mériterait d'être creusée
parce que
on voit par exemple les normes ISO
moi il se trouve que dans lorsque
j'étais président de chambre on a eu un
contentieux sur une norme ISO et on
s'est rendu compte à cette occasion que
effectivement c'est un continent
gigantesque des normes ISO qui donne
lieu en tout cas devant le juge
administratif à très peu de contentieux
ce qui est intéressant est-ce que c'est
grâce à sa mode à ces modalités très
particulières d'élaboration qui reposent
sur l'idée que on met autour de la table
les acteurs d'un secteur et on
fonctionne par consensus alors
d'ailleurs on avait été obligé de
définir ce que ça voulait dire qu'on
s'assus parce que justement l'espèce la
norme avait été adoptée alors même
qu'une partie de ceux qui avaient
participé donc est-ce que ça voulait
dire qu'il y avait quand même consensus
parce que global enfin voilà mais c'est
vrai que c'est une vraie question vous
soulevez et qui peut-être mérite qu'on
creuse certains aspects d'autant plus
que il y a encore un autre étage de
norme
enfin d'une forme de normalisation de
droits souples comme on dirait au
Conseil d'État qui est tout le
dispositif de la compliance
qui a tendance à se développer beaucoup
qui s'est développé encore tout
récemment je le signale parce que la
dernière étude du Conseil d'État portant
sur les réseaux sociaux
est sorti juste au moment où au niveau
européen était adopté le règlement les
règlements DMA et DSA digital market
actes et DJ tal services Act
dans règlement qui repose beaucoup sur
une logique de compliance c'est-à-dire
on dit aux réseaux sociaux bah voilà les
obligations auxquelles vous êtes
astreintes à vous de vous débrouiller
pour les mettre en oeuvre pour les
organiser et à vous de me montrer que
vous êtes capable
d'assurer une modération efficace avec
une logique qui est aussi intéressante
dans cette affaire parce qu'elle renvoie
à une question que vous posiez qui est
que le DMA et le DSA repose sur l'idée
que il faut être très exigeant avec les
très grandes plateformes
et modérément exigeant avec les
plateformes de taille moyenne et très
peu avec les petites donc avec une idée
du principe de proportionnalité auquel
le droit européen est très habitué mais
auquel nous sommes moins familiers il
faut reconnaître avec l'idée d'avoir
une norme j'allais dire un petit peu à
géométrie variable ce qui nous pose
aussi des problèmes pour nous par
rapport aux conception traditionnelles
du droit français mais voilà je le
mentionne parce que je trouve que c'est
quelque chose qui nous questionne et qui
en tout cas mérite que qu'on le regarde
la dernière question
sur le rapporteur sur le guichet unique
de de l'INPI alors je veux pas faire le
censeur de Limpy on a reçu enfin on a
auditionné le
président de Limpy qui nous a dit les
difficultés mais aussi tout ce qui
faisait pour essayer d'y remédier nous
ce qui nous apparaît de manière assez
frappante dans l'étude sur le dernier
kilomètre et
histoire du guichet unique en
illustrations c'est la tendance que nous
avons
à ne pas apprécier le l'expérimentation
le test
on n'aime pas ça parce qu'évidemment
c'est compliqué ça met en cause le
principe d'égalité parce qu'à l'heure on
va dire oui mais pourquoi
je bénéficie du guichet unique
en Seine-et-Marne n'importe quoi et pas
en Haute-Loire bon mais ce qui nous
manque très souvent c'est cette idée que
avant de généraliser un système de faire
le grand soir de la simplification comme
disait Charles togool mais il faut plus
modestement commencer par des
expérimentations des tâtonnements et
apparemment alors c'est une question
qu'on essaye aussi de creuser
apparemment c'est ce qui a été bien fait
s'agissant de la mise en place de du
prélèvement à la source il y a eu des
expérimentations des voilà et donc c'est
vrai que
on en est pas au stade de nos
recommandations mais de autant que je
veux pas mais l'idée que il plus
systématiquement montrer qu'on a
expérimenté ou au moins testé
concrètement sur le terrain ça serait
peut-être quelque chose qui serait au
moins aussi utile qu'une fiche d'impact
dont Charles tout boule rappelait les
conditions dans lesquelles elles sont
élaborées pour au moins qu'on puisse un
peu forcer à rentrer dans notre culture
administrative l'idée que avant de
généraliser on teste et on essaye de
voir ce qui marche pas voilà merci
beaucoup Jean-Pierre mega merci monsieur
le Président oui pour moi j'avais aussi
quelques questions qui rejoignent celle
de mon collègue dont je ne vais pas vous
les reposer vous avez répondu moi
j'avoue que je suis agréablement surpris
du travail que vous avez fait que vous
faites et ce souci de que vous avez
vraiment de simplifier même si la tâche
c'est pas facile et notamment d'essayer
de partager d'associer les
usagers pour essayer de mieux comprendre
les problèmes et vraiment
essayer de faire des choses qui sont
reprendre le terme le plus simple
possible après j'avais une question que
mon collègue vous avez pas posé mais
vous venez d'y répondre sur la place
qu'avait les directives européennes la
transposition et les surtransmission et
vous venez d'y répondre donc je ne vous
la repose pas je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'assez niveau et qui fait que moi
j'étais mère certaines de mes collègues
ou la plupart dans une autre vie je me
souviens de la simplification du Code de
l'Urbanisme j'avais un service qui
reviennent quand il a été simplifié il
était beaucoup plus épais que
Cavan qu'on le simplifie alors quand on
en parle comme ça on peut en parler dans
le souci en disant regardez il faisait
1500 pages maintenant il en fait 3000
mais enfin il y a tout un tas de
transposition de jurisprudence aussi qui
rentre dedans et qui plein de la je
dirais le le code et quand on croise un
peu
même si on n'est pas juriste par
comprendre que il y a des choses qui
sont malheureusement nécessaires
incontournables et je crois que les
directives européennes aussi mais vous
l'avez dit rentre
là-dedans voir moi je veux pas rajouter
autre chose vous avez déjà
répondu en tout cas je vous remercie de
la clarté de des propos des explications
que vous nous avez donné si
il y a une chose quand il y a des
nouvelles au nord ou des nouveaux textes
est-ce que vous explorez vraiment vous
regardez si on ne peut pas le supprimer
des anciens parce que on a l'impression
des fois qu'on a tellement de stocks de
de nouvelles normes de nouveaux textes
qui arrivent que
l’imposition comme peut-être on ne fait
pas toujours la poussière sur les
étagères derrière et qu'on pourrait
peut-être sortir certaines choses
sur la le fait de ne pas empiler les
normes il y a des dispositifs qui ont
été mis en place notamment une
circulaire de 2017 on appelle le 2 pour
qui oblige à supprimer deux normes
anciennes pour adopter une norme
nouvelle
il y a une version dégradée qui consiste
à dire qu'on tolère
lorsqu'on a une norme nouvelle au moins
la simplification de normes de normes
ancienne donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le
gage des normes ou le 2 pour 1 donc ça
marche au niveau réglementaire et ça a
produit des résultats et ça existe
toujours aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
qui est contrôlé par le cratère générale
du gouvernement là encore simplement
l'espace ça fait le lien avec ce que
disait Fabien Reynaud sur les
transpositions directives l'espace sur
lequel on peut jouer est en fait
extrêmement étroit
parce que
cette obligation qu'on peut faire peser
sur le pouvoir réglementaire elle n'a de
sens que pour autant que le pouvoir
réglementaire a lui-même de la marge de
manœuvre donc ça ne joue que ce qui
n'est pas de l'application de la loi ou
de la transposition de directive ce
qu'on appelle vraiment les règlements
autonomes ceux qui sont vraiment
d'initiatives du gouvernement et
complètement à sa main et en réalité
c'est très peu de choses dans la
production normative donc ces
dispositifs existent mais avec une
assiette si j'ose dire pour parler comme
en fiscal vraiment extrêmement étroite
et je crois vraiment que ça fait le lien
avec ce que disait Fabien Reynaud sur la
transposition des directives et c'est
quelque chose qui nous a frappé quand on
a fait l'étude de 2016 et je crois qu'il
faut le rappeler c'est l'idée je sais
pas s'il faut parler de ruissellement
des normes ou de cascades de normes mais
un règlement européen ça joue également
pour les règlements européens mais une
directive européenne ou un règlement
européen ça va produire de la loi
nationale qui va produire du décret en
Conseil d'État parfois du décret simple
très généralement de l'arrêté
ministériel parfois plusieurs arrêtés
ministériels bien souvent des
déclinaisons préfectorales tout ça va
amener des circulaires va amener des
circulaires ministériels circulaires
préfectorales des circulaires dans tous
les organismes qui vont devoir appliquer
la norme donc chaque mot qu'on écrit en
haut de la hiérarchie des normes ça en
produit des dizaines à l'étage du
dessous et donc il y a un coefficient
multiplicateur qu'il faut vraiment avoir
à l'esprit alors et Fabien Raynaud l'a
dit aussi au niveau européen ce constat
il est très présent tout le monde sait
comment ça se passe et pourtant la
France elle-même est très moteur pour
dire il faut que la construction
européenne progresse surtout pas qu'on
s'arrête il faut qu'on s'intègre de plus
en plus qu'on harmonise de plus en plus
les politiques publiques des États
membres et donc surtout ne nous arrêtons
pas de faire des directives voilà donc
il y a une espèce de schizophrénie
et si je la résumais de manière
caricaturale
je crois que c'est un peu c'est un peu
la schizophrénie entre entre le
politique et et l'administratif et
l'usager en clair
la politique c'est fait pour changer les
choses voilà et donc se dire que parce
que changer les choses ça produit de la
norme qui après vont peser sur les
administrer il faut s'arrêter c'est
impensable voilà je sais pas une
assemblée parlementaire je vais le dire
et ce phénomène voilà on le voit bien au
niveau européen on le voit bien je pense
dans les assemblées parlementaires on le
voit bien dans l'administration si on
veut vraiment aller au bout de la
logique et dire on va laisser souffler
l'usager
on va faire une pause
ça veut dire qu'en fait on arrête de
faire ce pourquoi beaucoup sont dans
leur fonction c'est-à-dire changer les
choses voilà et ça c'est c'est
probablement impossible et donc c'est un
équilibre qu'il faut trouver cette
solution cette solution de tout arrêter
est impossible et donc il faut trouver
un bon équilibre entre continuer de
légiférer au niveau européen au niveau
national continuer de faire des
règlements continuer de faire des
arrêtés préfectoraux mais voilà en ayant
bien à l'esprit que chaque chose qu'on
change ça fait sans doute progresser le
pays mais ça crée aussi une énorme
charge pour pour les dessinateurs et
trouver le trouver le bon équilibre
entre les deux et quelque chose de
vraiment difficile
simplement vous pouvez préciser le
chiffre du dans la simplification du
document ce que ça représente c'est de
l'ordre de quelques dizaines de décret
qui ont été évités
parce que la base est extrêmement
étroite
le champ des possibles c'est
considérable dans ce qu'on aurait pu
faire on est allé presque au bout sauf
que l'assiette est extrêmement étroite
et pour répondre à une question qui
figurait dans votre questionnaire si on
veut aller plus loin si on veut le
mettre au niveau législatif enfin il y a
deux approches soit celle que j'ai
évoquée à plusieurs reprises celle de se
fixer des engagements ça
le législateur peut le faire tout seul
les assemblées parlementaires peuvent le
faire elle-même si on veut contraindre
si on veut vraiment fixer une norme là
on est dans un champ qui est au mieux
organique probablement constitutionnel
en tout cas ça se jouera entre les deux
ça dépendra de la manière dont on écrit
[Musique]
ce que je voulais peut-être juste dire
pour faire écho à ce que disait monsieur
le rapporteur parce que le code de
l'urbanisme effectivement c'est un bon
exemple enfin moi je l'ai pas mal
pratiqué comme
président de chambre j'étais une des
chambres en charge de du contentieux
d'urbanisme c'est vrai que
il a beaucoup gonflé en partie pas
uniquement mais en partie aussi parce
que on a essayé d'y intégrer législateur
d'ailleurs suivi à cet égard des des
propositions qui avaient été faites par
des groupes de travail notamment un
groupe de travail présidé par une membre
éminente du Conseil d'État pour mettre
en place des dispositifs justement qui
visait à simplifier la vie des
demandeurs de d'autorisation d'urbanisme
en s'assurant que lorsque la demande
d'urbanisme enfin lorsque l'autorisation
d'urbanisme délivrée aux demandeurs
comporte un vice mais qui n'est pas un
vice qui
le projet radicalement impossible mais
qui peut être régularisé alors que ce
vice puisse être régularisé soit par un
renvoi du juge vers l'administration
soit directement devant le juge avec un
échange entre le pétitionnaire
l'administration et évidemment le
requérant qui est évidemment la boucle
donc tout ça pour dire que évidemment
plus on apprécié tout ça dans le code ou
de la même manière plus on a précisé la
liste exhaustive des documents qui
peuvent être demandés ça rallonge le
code donc c'est là toute la complexité
de que souligner Charles Touboul entre
l'allongement purement quantitatif mais
quels sont ses effets concrets en termes
de complexification voilà c'est c'est
plus nuancé je crois et la dernière
chose que je voulais dire c'est par
rapport au droit européen
je pense que il y a une évolution que
moi personnellement je trouve assez
intéressantes mais qui peut-être suscite
plus de critiques de la part du du
Parlement c'est l'idée que moi quand
j'ai commencé dans les affaires
européennes c'était il y a une vingtaine
d'années on ne faisait pas de règlement
enfin en tout cas la France était très
très hostile à ce qu'on recouvre au
règlement on en faisait très très peu
parce qu'on disait il faut que ce soit
des directives pour que on transpose
chez nous aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup moins certaines
interdiction on a beaucoup plus souvent
recours au Règlement on l'a vu avec le
rgpd là je parlais du DMA et du DSA je
trouve que c'est une évolution qui est
intéressante dans la mesure où dans
certains domaines on a intérêt à avoir
plutôt un texte européen qui cadre les
choses de manière enfin une fois pour
toutes j'allais dire et éviter qui est
la multiplication des textes de
transposition qui en plus font que non
seulement on a le ruissellement pour
parler Charles de Gaulle mais en plus
c'est introduit pour les entreprises des
différences minimes mais qui peuvent
être lourdes conséquence entre ce que ce
qui a été écrit en Allemagne qui a été
écrit en France etc mais tout ça ne
marche qu'à condition que on joue le jeu
nous-même et que lorsque on met notre
droit en conformité avec le règlement on
le fait à minima
j'entendais dire que le projet de loi de
enfin pas de transposition puisque c'est
règlement mais sur le DMA lDSA faisait
une centaine de pages c'est j'ai pas
regardé c'est justifie peut-être
complètement mais je trouve que il faut
qu'on fasse attention parce que la
logique du règlement si c'est pour
remettre une couche de de droit français
de manière excessive alors on perd sur
tous les tableaux
merci on va devoir conclure donc je
demande la parole peut-être à nos
collègues qui sont là avant simplement
une remarque parce que évidemment notre
délégation aux entreprises rencontrent
beaucoup d'entreprises on va au devant
sur le terrain et ce qu'on entend
toujours la part des entreprises ça
évolue dans leur revendications à une
époque c'était la fiscalité qui faisait
croulaient sous les charges maintenant
c'est plus ça c'est l'emploi et la
réglementation et il nous il nous accuse
d'ailleurs d'y participer mais le
paradoxe c'est que souvent les
entreprises
demandent aussi de la réglementation je
ferme cette parenthèse on a quand même
essayé de chiffrer cela ce poids et le
mouvement de ce ti le métier nous
indiquait que parents il y avait 700
nouvelles normes pour les entreprises de
taille métisse c'est-à-dire au-delà de
250 salariés mais avec un stock actif de
le reste étant considéré comme
obsolescent mais existant toujours Harry
du stock actif donc ça fait beaucoup à
gérer
ça fait beaucoup à gérer en flux et
imaginons pour les entreprises plus
petites où il y a aucun service dédié
et pas de capacité forcément financière
de faire appel à des grands spécialistes
à chaque occasion c'est une vraie
difficulté quoi c'est l'un des sujets
qui nous a incités à prendre en charge
cette réflexion
dans le cas des auditions qu'on avait
faites à l'époque on avait eu un peu le
même message déjà et ce qui nous est
frappé c'est que au-delà même de la
quantité au delà de la complexité ce qui
exaspéré les entreprises c'était
l'instabilité
on nous a très souvent dit
bon il y a beaucoup de normes elles sont
elles sont presquis lisibles mais tant
qu'elle bouge pas on les connaît on
apprend à vivre avec on a en quelque
sorte dompter sa complexité
on sait on sait acclimaté et donc
pour tirer les conséquences de cela
c'était d'ailleurs avant même l'étude du
Conseil d'État il y a des dispositifs
qui ont été mis en place spécifiquement
pour les entreprises comme vous le savez
notamment les fameuses dates communes
d'entrée en vigueur ça c'est un
dispositif qui je crois marche assez
bien alors ça ne vaut bien sûr que pour
le réglementaire c'est cette idée que on
essaye de lister les normes qui sont
spécifiquement applicables aux
entreprises ça apparaît sur les
gifrances et surtout on fixe un
calendrier vous montrer en vigueur et on
essaye de regrouper les entrées en
vigueur à quelques dates clés dans
l'année voilà pour que les entreprises
notamment les petites n’est pas à
surveiller avec anxiété le Journal
Officiel tous les matins pour savoir ce
qui leur tombe dessus et qu'elle sache
que voilà tous les trimestres d'ailleurs
les dates communes qui sont proposées
elles sont indicatives pour
l'administration mais elles ont été
réfléchies avec ce souci de coller à des
dates qui sont connues par exemple
soit pour des raisons comptables soit de
pour des raisons fiscales donc on est
sur 1er avril 1er juillet enfin bref des
dates qui sont assez
intuitifs pour les entreprises cette
idée que voilà à ces moments-là il y a
des blocs de normes qui vont arriver et
qui vont devoir être mises en oeuvre et
ça fait partie des choses petites choses
qui je crois ont aidé les entreprises et
qui fonctionnent depuis maintenant
quelques années il y a sans doute
d'autres choses à faire mais c'était un
point que je souhaitais rappeler puisque
ça fonctionne et c'est spécifique aux
entreprises merci donc pour pour
terminer nos échanges je vais passer la
parole à Vincent c'est quoi
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
c'est très intéressant de vous entendre
moi je suis un rapporteur sur un autre
texte c'était sur celui de la balance
commerciale
on a visité d'autres pays
on s'est aperçu quand même que les
autres pays nous ont dit l'Allemagne et
l'Italie notamment qu'ils avaient une
administration qui était plutôt aidante
plutôt que
on a fait un parallèle avec
l'administration française bon on s'est
dit la France apporte des contraintes
supplémentaires qui ne cessent de
enfin on veut on veut tout cadrer on
n'aime pas les espaces de liberté les
espaces et donc ce qui nous pose
problème dans la création et dans
l'investissement des nouvelles
entreprises et puis dans les projets des
jeunes
aujourd'hui on est quand même arrivé à
un niveau
très inquiétant puisque la balance
commerciale est quand même ultra
déficitaire nos entreprises on
s'aperçoit qu'elles vont plutôt
s'implanter à l'extérieur on n'est plus
capable de faire des dolipranes parce
que il y a bien-être animal pour faire
sûrement pour faire de l'expérience
d'expérimentation donc en France c'est
très compliqué et en parallèle je suis
aussi sur l'agriculture ou on commence à
être très affolé par la balance
commerciale qui devient de plus en plus
déficitaire et bien sûr en vous écoutant
un sujet on revient
en tête c'est les nicotinoïdes par
exemple sur le sucre
donc
on a vraiment une inquiétude majeure
l'Allemagne va repulvériser les
nicotinoïdes alors qu'ils sont vraiment
ineffiques enfin qui sont dangereux pour
l'abeille
donc ils vont sauvegarder leur
entreprise du sucre
nous avons les mêmes lois et nous nous
allons plus pouvoir et pendre et donc
nous allons constater la fermeture des
sucrières ma question c'est
le président de la République c'était
engagé à ce qui est plus de normes de
surtransposition
je vous ai entendu vous réfléchissez au
système pour essayer de les éviter pour
essayer de les réduire pour supprimer
les décrets à la fois ministériel ou
diminuer décrets et des interprétations
aussi ministères au niveau ministériel
mais aussi au niveau départemental mais
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le problème est
devenu vraiment un problème majeur et il
faut plus qu'on soit à l'état de
réfléchir et de trouver des solutions il
faut qu'on soit actif il faut qu'on
change des mentalités
alors ça c'est mon avis personnel je
croyais beaucoup dans le cnen quand
il s'est installé en disant peut-être
que voilà il va y avoir on va on va
stopper un peu la schizophrénie donc
vous avez parlé et donc
j'en reviens sur ces normes de
surtransposition
par rapport à l'engagement du chef de
l'État qu'en est-il
et le deuxième point comment vous
expliquer que l'Allemagne et la France
est sans arrêt une interprétation qui
soit différente
et sur les surtransposition
ce que je disais c'est que
il y a quelques années j'ai présidé un
groupe de travail sur la question des
surtranspositions enfin groupe de
travail au Conseil d'État sur cette
question et on s'était rendu compte que
en réalité il y avait différents types
de surtranspositions et que il était
assez
il était beaucoup plus difficile que ce
qu'on pensait initialement de pouvoir
lutter contre et je vais donner
l'exemple de d'une directive qui impacte
une partie d'un régime juridique qui en
droit français était unifié et au stade
de la transposition du coup on se pose
le problème soit on transpose
strictement la directive mais alors en
désunifie le régime juridique soit on
étend le champ des obligations de la
directive à l'ensemble du régime
juridique pour que
il soit il continue à être unifié ce qui
est généralement souhaité par les
utilisateurs donc c'est vrai que ces
questions de sur disposition sont des
questions difficiles par ailleurs moi
j'ai comme je le disais j'ai pas mal
fréquenté les affaires européennes une
des explications à la question que vous
soulevez sur
l'interprétation différente entre la
France et l'Allemagne c'est que
généralement au début de la négociation
les deux pôles opposés c'est la France
et l'Allemagne et que pour toutes sortes
de raisons les intérêts différents les
voilà l'héritage historique différent le
fonctionnement administratif et que donc
le lorsque la négociation est bien
conduite
ce qui est statistiquement est quand
même le cas le point d'équilibre à la
fin est un compromis franco-allemand et
donc
il est assez naturel que ensuite chacun
essaye de d'interpréter le compromis
avec ses lunettes si j'ose dire et le
rôle de la commission étant de veiller
ensuite est-ce que l'interprétation
reste la même
après sur la question des néonic moi il
se trouve que j'ai été
juge des référés dans deux affaires sur
les néonicotinoïdes ou j'ai été saisi
par le Conseil d'État a été saisi par
les les
syndicats de représentant les industries
sucrières la difficulté là c'est que
pour le coup il y a un choix politique
là c'est vraiment un choix politique
très très fort
qui a été d'ailleurs qui s'est traduit
par
un vote du Parlement français
en faveur d'une alors on a reporté on
avait reporté de deux ans la date limite
mais on a décidé de pas
reporter au-delà donc les Allemands ont
fait un choix politique différent là
c'est vraiment et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que cette question de
surtransposition quand on la regarde en
réalité secteur par secteur on se rend
compte qu'il y a d'une part les
difficultés techniques auxquelles je
faisais allusion sur les régimes unifiés
qu'on ne veut pas des unifier et puis
par ailleurs il y a aussi dit souvent
après une politique qui est que on ne
veut pas abaisser le niveau d'ambition
si j'ose dire alors quand c'est par
exemple la protection des consommateurs
on ne veut pas
baisser le niveau de protection des
consommateurs dans notre régime pour
s'aligner sur le compromis qui a été
trouvé au niveau européen généralement
d'ailleurs dans la négociation on se bat
pour obtenir la possibilité de maintenir
un régime plus protecteur en France et
donc ensuite on le maintient donc du
coup c'est une forme de surtransposition
mais ça ça renvoie un choix politique et
dans le domaine environnemental c'est
souvent le cas également c'est à dire
que voilà on veut pour des raisons qui
là pour le coup qui m'appartient
absolument pas sur lequel il
m'appartient absolument pas de me
prononcer mais on veut être en avance
donc
là il y a une difficulté qui vraiment ne
se résout qu'à un niveau très politique
me semble-t-il
merci on va
politique ils sont parfois
terriblement dévastateur sur les
territoires il y a une première usine de
sucrerie qui ferme aujourd'hui à
Beauvais
voilà ça commence
et les Allemands se régalent parce
qu'ils sont à 200 km de lave livrer le
sucre
merci monsieur
[Musique]
pensez
aux commerces
chers collègues que je salue également
qui ont après une nuit
allez je ne mets pas de qualificatif
mais c'est gentil d'être là ce matin
nous poursuivons avec cette deuxième
audition conjointe nos travaux soient
simplification
des normes applicables aux entreprises
évidemment on a le plaisir d'accueillir
deux acteurs du choc de simplification
de 2013
en effet vous avez monsieur le fonction
respectives mais il y en a cette
première politique globale en faveur des
entreprises dans le précédent rapport de
la délégation des entreprises avaient
dressé un bilan mitigé en 2017
bon Monsieur Thierry Mandon en étant
chargé de la simplification au sein du
gouvernement comme secrétaire d'État
c'est le Ministre à ce moment-là et
Monsieur Laurent grandguillaume en
co-président avec un chef d'entreprise
monsieur Guillaume Poitrinal du groupe
Unibail Rodamco le conseil de
simplification pour les entreprises
quelles leçons diriez-vous de cette
expérience pourquoi l'impôt papier c'est
à dire le coût pesant sur les
entreprises est-il si lourd en France
comment l'alléger
[Musique]
nous vous remercions grandement d'avoir
accepté évidemment notre invitation à
cette audition je céderai tout d'abord
la parole pour un propos liminaire d'une
durée de 10 minutes chacun puis nous
rapporteurs vous interrogeront à leur
tour avant que nous prenions les
questions de nos collègues donc je suis
entouré de deux des trois rapporteurs
Gilbert Luc de finale et Jean-Pierre
Moga qui vous poseront quelques
questions
issues de votre propos luminaire alors
si vous le souhaitez on peut commencer
peut-être la parole à Monsieur
ganguillaume pour commencer puis j'ai le
ministre
voilà allez-y merci monsieur le
Président mais c'est quoi rapporteur et
madame monsieur et sénateurs
pour cette cet échange sur le choc de
simplification et l'ensemble des actions
qui ont été mises en œuvre dans ce cadre
à travers le conseil de simplification
le secrétariat d'État ensuite à la
simplification et on va dire les mesures
qui ont été votées par le Parlement sur
lesquels l'avaient travaillé d'ailleurs
les députés et les sénateurs puisque
chaque mesure
lorsqu'elle ne relevait pas que du
pouvoir réglementaire faisait l'objet
soit d'amendement soit de loi
d'habilitation qui ont été traités dans
ce cadre
donc avec le recul moi ce que je peux
dire c'est que d'abord la méthode était
collaborative et l'associer à la fois
les acteurs publics les acteurs privés
entreprises bien sûr et puis l'ensemble
des experts qui pouvaient intervenir sur
ces domaines c'est-à-dire que finalement
la société civile était force de
proposition
vis-à-vis d'un espace de dialogue qui
réunissait le monde des acteurs publics
et le monde des acteurs privés donc un
espace de dialogue de concertation là où
les entrepreneurs avaient parfois du mal
à trouver tout simplement une écoute
bienveillante pour pouvoir faire part de
leurs difficultés dans un monde où
finalement les normes
sont parfois des contraintes et parfois
aussi des éléments de protection on le
sait au niveau international l'enjeu des
normes au niveau international est aussi
un sujet très important
ce qui a bien fonctionné ça a été le
lien avec les administrations le
dialogues permanent l'élaboration des
des 50 mesures qui étaient présentées
régulièrement et puis le suivi
d'ailleurs de leur mise en œuvre et donc
beaucoup d'actions ont été mises en
œuvre peut-être même parfois trop c'est
à dire qu'il y avait un mélange entre
des actions on va dire avec un petit
impact et d'autres avec un attaque très
important quand on traite de la
déclaration sociale nominative par
exemple et que l'on traite dans le même
temps de la suppression d'une micro taxe
pouvant percuter tel ou telle activité
on n'était pas tout à fait sur les mêmes
enjeux donc ça pouvait peut-être parfois
laisser penser qu'il y avait un
foisonnement de disposition et pas de
priorisation et ce qui était pourtant
pas le cas donc puisqu'il y avait bien
une priorisation sur les mesures les
plus impactantes pour les entreprises
pour créer des gains pour l'économie
je rappelle que à l'époque Thierry
Mandon avait nous avait invité
dès le début du quinquennat rencontré à
rencontrer Dan bredinitz qui était un
conseiller de Barack Obama sur les
politiques industrielles qui nous avait
expliqué justement avant même que ces
gens des simplification soit lancée tout
l'impact du travail qui avait été fait
aux États-Unis pour réindustrialiser le
pays et sur la question en particulier
de la simplification des normes mais
aussi du traitement de la simplification
dans les territoires parce qu'une
entreprise par nature a une empreinte
sociale économique et économique dans
son territoire et c'est très important
de relier aussi cette question au
territoire
là où nous avons rencontré assez
rapidement des difficultés ça a été en
particulier à un moment donné dans le
dialogue avec le secrétariat général du
gouvernement puisque nous avions initié
l'idée qu'il fallait sur chaque projet
de décret en particulier et de textes
réglementaire invité des entrepreneurs
pour qu'ils puissent tout simplement
nous faire part des points de vigilance
avant même la publication de ces textes
donc on avait réussi à mettre en place
un groupe de travail avec le secrétaire
général du gouvernement pour justement
étudier les potentiels impacts de tel ou
telle mesure réglementaire bon ça n'a
pas tenu longtemps parce que ça n'a pas
été ensuite pérennisé avec le changement
en 2017 et c'est bien dommage car je
pense vraiment qu'il n'y a pas dans ce
domaine d'impact puissant sans inscrire
cette politique sur le long terme
on voit bien que il faut bien distinguer
le quoi et les objectifs la cible que
l'on veut atteindre pour notre économie
française à travers le renforcement de
sa compétitivité en particulier et dans
le même temps se dire que le comment on
met en œuvre ces dispositions il est
seul à prendre du temps il faut du temps
nécessaire tant nécessaire pour
l'élaboration tant nécessaire pour la
délibération puisque forcément bien
évidemment il faut que le Parlement soit
associé et pas que à l'ensemble de ces
mesures et ce temps de la délibération
est nécessaire pour que l'impact soit
durable et qu'il puisse être aussi
évalué par par le Parlement à travers
les différentes commissions de contrôle
en particulier donc c'est je pense a été
je crois une réussite
à la fois dans son lancement et dans
l'impact qui a été généré on peut
regretter d'ailleurs en ce domaine comme
dans bien d'autres qu'il n'y ait pas eu
une véritable étude d'impact sur les
effets directs et sur les effets
indirects des mesures de simplification
on sait que c'est souvent là
[Musique]
nous aurions pris cette décision elle
n'a pas été mise en oeuvre pour
différentes raisons en 2017 globalement
tout s'arrête même si une délégation a
terminal il a quand même beaucoup de
choses qui sont arrêtées dans l'élan qui
avait été projeté et donc on a fait
appel à moi donc l'année dernière pour
une mission pour le gouvernement pour
faire quoi pour mettre en place ce
guichet unique à travers un rapport que
j'ai remis à la Direction Générale des
Entreprises et d'ailleurs le site
entreprendre point service-république.fr
a été lancé suite à ce rapport il a
fallu neuf mois pour créer l'ensemble du
site et en s'appuyant sur les travaux de
la villa de la dilemme de la DGE de la
DG FIP et puis de la cause puisque il a
fallu rassembler tous ces acteurs et
finalement faire une forme de médiation
entre tous ces acteurs publics pour
arriver à faire converger et ça a été
une réussite mais vous voyez bien
qu'entre le moment où on a pris la
décision c'est en 2015 et le moment où
on a mis en oeuvre un site il a fallu
finalement sept ans cette année pourquoi
parce que nous avons perdu entre 2017 et
2022 près de 5 ans finalement dans la
mise en oeuvre de cette disposition qui
était attendue de tous et qui avait été
demandé par les entrepreneurs qu'ils
soient travailleurs indépendants
entrepreneur d'une TPE d'une PME ou
d'une entreprise internet intermédiaire
parce que je rappelle qu'il y a un gros
enjeu en France sur le passage la
croissance des PME vers les ETI et le
soutien nosotéi qui sont vraiment les
pépites de l'économie française et voilà
donc on a réussi donc c'est bien mais on
a perdu du temps et donc je moi voilà
l'enseignement on va dire que que
j'aurai et puis je continue par ailleurs
être engagé sur des expérimentations en
particulier sur territoire zéro chômeur
longue durée
c'est que on a besoin de d'avoir un
changement culturel aussi sur ces
questions là dans le pays et d'inscrire
la question du comment dans la durée
comment on met en oeuvre comment on
mobilise l'ensemble des forces et
comment on inscrit sur du long terme
pour qu'il y ait un réel impact des
actions mises en oeuvre donc ce serait
plutôt voilà à travers ce proposifs un
appel à la remobilisation pour le futur
dans ce domaine qui est indispensable si
l'on veut justement être compétitif dans
une économie mondiale où voilà il y a
beaucoup de concurrence sur ces
questions de normes et ces questions de
simplification pour les entreprises et
d'accélération de l'innovation en
particulier
merci pour votre attention
merci Monsieur ministre
[Musique]
sénatrice peut-être en complément de ce
que vient de d'expliquer Laurent
Guillaume
d'abord la genèse de cette politique
publique de la simplification
pour la période
2013 enfin 2013-2017 laquelle j'étais
impliqué avec Laurent et avec plein de
gens et
le président de la République c'est
intéressé à ce sujet au moment du choc
de compétitivité
de 2012
et
via son ministre de l'Économie des
Finances j'étais à l'époque
parlementaire m'a demandé de faire un
rapport
sur
la simplification voilà ce qu'il fallait
faire comment il fallait s'y prendre
et ce rapport très vite d'abord j'ai
commencé à le faire en ayant ce que tout
à fait classique une vision
rétrospective qu'est-ce que la France
avait fait dans ce domaine depuis
quelques années ça a pas commencé en
2013 ça a commencé avant il y avait
d'ailleurs des choses tout à fait bien
Lambert notamment vous connaissez avec
les choses très bien mais on se rendait
bien compte que
dans ce très bref regard rétrospectif on
se rendrait bien compte qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui clochait
que et en gros que ça a été de l'ordre
du stop and go
ça s'arrête ça redémarre les acquis
d'une période sont laissées tomber bon
bref donc ensuite j'ai eu la curiosité
de m'intéresser à la façon dont s'y
prenait les autres pays européens
et j'ai fait le tour d'Europe pendant le
temps des mois et des mois pour vérifier
enfin voir
la façon dont les Allemands s'y
prenaient les Anglais s'y prenaient les
Belges s'y prenaient les danoisypres les
Suédois s'y prenaient les Italiens s'y
prenaient enfin j'ai vraiment fait un
travail assez poussé de d'analyse
et de tout ça
sont sortis plusieurs convictions
qu'on a essayé de mettre en oeuvre
ensuite donc à partir de 2013 2014 la
création du Conseil de simplification
premièrement il faut un outil
cette politique publique a besoin d'un
outil j'allais dire entre guillemets
indépendant pas indépendant du
gouvernement
rattaché à quelqu'un au gouvernement et
tout tout les mots que j'utilise là sont
des moins importants parce que la
définition du quelqu'un
est très importante est-ce que c'est le
premier ministre
comme en Angleterre est-ce que c'est le
ministre de l'économie
et des finances ou des
peu importe les dénominations naturelles
comme en Allemagne comme au Danemark il
faut mais il faut un outil deuxièmement
il faut que cet outil sert une stratégie
très claire vous avez vous dans votre
réflexion aujourd'hui
une stratégie enfin un élément que vous
avez souligné qui est la simplification
outil de productivité des entreprises
si j'ai bien compris votre angle
tous les pays n'ont pas forcément cette
axe là ou plus exactement n'ont pas
forcément que cet axe là il y a des gens
qui disent
la simplification outil de réduction des
dépenses publiques
c'est un objectif prioritaire il y a des
gens qui disent la simplification outil
de rapprochement des usagers
de la puissance publique donc là c'est
plus les sous c'est comment on fait pour
que ça marche mieux donc il faut une
stratégie
deuxième correction un outil une
stratégie 3 une démarche collaborative
ce que vient de l'expliquer parfaitement
l'orange on rentre pas là-dedans on
simplifie pas par décision de de suprême
d'administration intelligente qui savent
ce qui est bon pour le pays
on simplifie à partir de l'expérience
usagée comme on dit maintenant c'était
ce mot est à la mode mais c'était
exactement ça qui sont les victimes de
la complexité
quel agenda ces victimes définissent
pour entre guillemets
alléger leur fardeau qui soit financier
qui soit mental le mal-être que crée
donc il faut que ce soit collaboratif
quatrièmement il faut que les missions
de cet outil soit très précise parce que
et là vous avez des modèles très
différents vous avez un modèle vous
pouvez demander à l'outil ce que nous
avons fait nous c'est le choix que nous
avions fait d'élaborer des propositions
à partir de l'agenda des acteurs donc
nous de simplification de pour les
entreprises avait des groupes de travail
qui étaient calés sur les moments de vie
des entreprises recrutées produire
exporter donc il y avait des groupes de
travail paritaires avec des entreprises
des administration et on leur disait
qu'est-ce que vous souffrez de quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il faut prioritairement
pour vous faire simplifier donc
c'était de l'ordre de l'élaboration de
la proposition il y a des outils en
Europe
qui ont un autre objectif qui est de
formuler des avis éclairés ils sont
collaboratifs sur des textes
législatifs en amont des textes
législatifs ou sur des arrêtés des
décisions administratives qui
s'apprêtent à prix je pense au NKR le
Normand contrôlera tellement lui il fait
pas de proposition
c'est pas son boulot son boulot c'est
chaque fois qu'il va y avoir un texte de
loi de dire écoutez c'est très bien mais
voilà ce que et ses avis sont publics
très concrètement voilà ce que ça va
créer comme charge ou comme complexité
ou comme
difficulté pour l'économie je me
rappelle très bien de la suite qui avait
été faite au moment où les Allemands ont
fait le SMIC qui est quand même pas rien
à l'époque où ça fait le revenu minimum
ils sont passés donc ils ont défini
c'était 9 9 50 je crois euro de l'heure
le monde contrôlate s'est réuni il a dit
écoutez
choix politique pas de problème à la
dire ça va créer une charge de 45
milliards pour l'économie allemande
c'est pas notre problème sachez-le et ça
va faire disparaître deux professions
l'école porteurs de journaux les
ramasseurs les cueilleurs de cerises
parce que c'est pas possible le modèle
économique de ces professions là ne
supportent pas donc solution 1 vous le
fait vous les exonérer de cette charge
mais c'est difficile solution de vous la
faites une montée en régime sur 10 ans
ce qui a été fait et résultat la
manœuvre la mise en place du SMIC a été
votée à l'unanimité de la chambre donc
ça peut formuler des avis 3 ça peut
ça là je pense aux Anglais prends en
charge le travail de
suivi et de modifications des normes
c'est à dire ça devient un outil
d'instruction donc là on est plus ni
dans la proposition ni dans la vie mais
on est dans l'outil d'instruction avant
vote de la simplification et puis
quatrièmement c'est certain d'autres
papa tous ça peut être des outils
d'évaluation excentés avant
expose après
nous dans notre idée on en parlant moi
je veux pas dire moi parce que je
travaillais plein de gens et d'abord les
entreprises Guillaume prêtre et des
acteurs comme comme Laurent et plein
d'autres parlementaires de tout bord
d'ailleurs c'était c'est super nous on
s'est dit
on regardera la situation française il
faut un qu'on fasse les propositions
de les avis
c'est même pas la peine on peut le faire
mais on se fera plaisir parce que quand
on voyait déjà l'indigence qui demeure
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière un peu
moins mais des études d'impact on voit
pas pourquoi les études d'impact n'étant
pas prise au sérieux pourquoi des avis
d'impact le serait beaucoup plus c'est
triste mais donc on a tiré un trait
là-dessus 3 la prise en charge du
travail il faut qu'on amorce ce point-là
d'où le fait qu'on avait mis dans le
conseil de simplification des haut
fonctionnaires que j'avais pris à mon
cabinet la secrétaire général adjoint du
gouvernement qui est une conseillère
d'État parce que du coup on était
capable de produire de la prédécision
juridiquement sécure et quatre sur
l'évaluation ça a été je vous le livre
tel que je vous le la franchise m'oblige
à le faire le plus difficile parce que
là on se heurte aujourd'hui avec on
s'était heurté pardon à cette époque là
au service de Bercy qui avait les seules
compétences qualités et moyens pour
faire ce travail là mais eux avaient un
outil d'évaluation et ont toujours
d'ailleurs un outil d'évaluation de la
charge créée par les normes qui est un
outil
Méline Bercy
alors que tous les pays européens ont un
outil commun qui s'appelle le standard
cosmodel qui a le double avantage
d'avoir une méthodologie éprouvée et qui
permet des comparatifs entre pays
européens et là on s'est très rare
d'être rendu compte que et qu'on n'y
arrivera pas et donc par rapport à ce
que peut faire un outil indépendant on
s'en est tenu de fait
à la mission 1
identifier les propositions à la mission
allez le plus en aval possible dans la
décision pour qu'il y ait plus qu'à
appuyer sur un bouton pour que pour que
ça se fasse et puis on a tourné un petit
peu autour de la question de
l'évaluation je vous dirai comment en 2
minutes et là j'arrête après parce que
je risque d'être d'être trop long il
n'empêche que cette politique évidemment
elle peut pas vous dire le contraire est
une politique
extraordinairement innovante en matière
simplification en français le mérité de
d'être
dès le départ mais on le savait pas puis
on prototype à une politique
inscrite comme une politique durable en
même temps il faut un consensus des
acteurs il y a France stratégie qui
publie des rapports tout à fait
intéressants enfin que qui de fait
irrigue assez peu la décision publique
si on avait la moitié des moyens de
France stratégie pour faire une mission
de 10 ans de simplification des des des
normes pesant sur les entreprises je
vous assure que ça fera un choc
considérable de compétit donc
on a beaucoup regretté ça ça a très bien
marché et d'ailleurs j'avais été assez
froissé moi par le rapport réalisé en
2017 par le Sénat qui nous avait pas
entendu d'ailleurs je sais pas toi mais
moi pas je pense personne donc
parce que je trouvais que c'était
injuste l'aspect innovant c'est
politique au moins soit pas pris en
compte après il y a des limites
nous-mêmes on voit donc d'ailleurs dont
je vous parle mais ça très bien marché
le président de la République s'est
investi personnellement
tous les six mois il faisait un bilan il
convoquait tous ces directeurs
d'administration centrale
bon alors on en est où de ce qui a été
décidé il y a six mois on en est où à
l'Élysée on en est où de des
propositions là dans 6 mois et on
faisait ça jusqu'à ce que les attentats
finalement modifient la marche du
quinquennat et il fasse que ça redescend
à Matignon puis après malheureusement ça
c'est un peu un tout petit peu un tout
petit peu donc il faut une très très
forte volonté il faut une une
organisation et puis surtout il faut une
évaluation
objective des gains concrets pour les
entreprises donc nous on a essayé de
faire ça en utilisant le seul outil dont
on disposait puisqu'on n'avait aucun
moyen on n'a pas de budget de conseil il
a jamais eu un centime
pas un permanent
on avait réussi à faire financer une
toute petite étude par attention qui a
que j'ai que vous avez j'imagine sinon
je vous la ferai passer c'est pas vrai
qui a montré que le gain des mesures
prises effectivement prises pouvaient
être chiffré à minimum 4 milliards et
demi
de charges en moins pour les entreprises
mais ils ont évalué parce qu'on n'avait
pas les sous que le tiers je crois des
mesures qui ont été prises donc ça
tourne entre 7 et 8 milliards avec des
gains considérables notamment la
déclaration sociale numérique est un
représente beaucoup de beaucoup de de
ces gains et donc mais il a évidemment
manqué manqué de cette de cette armature
je conclure en disant que
je pense qu'il faut faire exactement
comme on avait fait mais en tout cas
cette politique est plus indispensable
que jamais je crois même que mais là
c'est de la politique
baissé durablement la fiscalité pesant
sur les entreprises ce heurtera de plus
en plus à des réticences de l'opinion
publique c'est déjà le cas qui voit bien
que que finalement d'abord il y a des
des des questions fiscales qui se posent
au regard de bénéfices de certains
entreprises mais au-delà de ça c'est
l'idéologie
au-delà de ça que des recettes en moins
d'entreprises et du déficit public parce
que on n'arrive pas à dépenser à réduire
les dépenses publiques à la vitesse à
laquelle on baisse la fiscalité sur les
entreprises
et que d'une certaine manière la
simplification sur lesquelles les gars
sont considérables mais considérables
encore à venir est un vrai outil sinon
l'outil privilégié de compétitivité des
entreprises donc
je serais persuadé qu'il faut remonter
un outil l'installer dans la durée ça
peut être fait par consensus politique
parce que
les bases que j'ai donné le tour
d'Europe
vaguement parlé enfin j'ai plein de
documents là-dessus si la Commission en
a besoin je les tiens à sa disposition
mais mais que c'est c'est d'une certaine
manière plus urgent que que jamais
est-ce qu'on se limite aux entreprises
est-ce qu'on fait un volet aussi citoyen
rapprochement des citoyens je pense
qu'il faut le faire parce que c'est plus
facile je prends un truc un scandale
national aujourd'hui le renouvellement
des passeports et des cartes d'identité
moi je suis allé en Géorgie et je suis
allé dans un centre commercial où il y a
un bureau
dans un centre commercial il y a un
bureau du ministère de l'Intérieur vous
arrivez le matin vous donnez votre
passeport en Géorgie avec tous les
problèmes géopolitiques qu'il y a fait
vos courses pour passer le soir vous
avez votre passeport
bon faut quand même pas rigoler on est
dans la farce donc je pense que
y compris si on veut vraiment mettre le
paquet sur les entreprises il faut
trouver quelque chantier de progrès sur
les sur les citoyens mais voilà je m'en
tiens là pour l'instant
je vais passer la partie
la parole peut-être c'est cette fois
Jean-Pierre merci monsieur le président
monsieur
le ministre monsieur vous nous avez donc
fait une présentation de la manière dont
vous voyez les choses par rapport à la
simplification vous parliez d'outils de
stratégie
vous avez été secrétaire de 2017 je
crois
bon il y a eu un rapport important de
qui est là du Conseil d'État sur la
simplification
des normes il y avait notamment
d'associer vous l'avez évoqué
d'associer les citoyens les entreprises
qui étaient concernés par les par les
nouvelles normes est-ce que vous pensez
que depuis votre départ les choses ont
sont allés dans ce sens sont progresser
et ont permis de
j'irai pas de simplifier en tout cas de
faire mieux comprendre les les choses à
ceux qui qui se heurtent à l'utilisation
des normes au quotidien ensuite le
deuxième point que je voulais évoquer
c'est que on a beaucoup de normes
tous les jours il sort de quasiment oui
de nouvelles normes puisque président de
700 700 norme par an
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu'on
a fait un vrai travail pour essayer de
dépoussiérer les anciennes normes parce
que
à ce rythme là on a fixé complètement
les les gens les entreprises sous les
normes et est-ce qu'il y a un réel
travail de
diminution
des normes est-ce qu'on fait
suffisamment le ménage pour que les gens
arrivent à s'y à s'y retrouver le
l'autre point c'est les
transpositions et les
et sur transposition bon transpose et ça
c'est normal les directives européennes
mais est-ce que vous croyez pas que si
il y a des surfacances positions
que l'on a fait qui sont regrettables
alors moi je suis du pays de la de la
noisette on a des cerises aussi bon on a
plus de néonicotinoïdes partout en
Europe il y en a et comme on a sur
transposer certaines choses et bien
aujourd'hui on achète les noisettes à
l'étranger
elle le sont traitées
c'est pareil pour les cerises et je sais
que c'est aussi à peu près pareil pour
les olives ce sol les
exemples de
d'application de sur
transposition bon voilà dans un premier
temps les questions que je souhaitais
vous vous posez en tout cas je vous
remercie d'exposer que vous venez de
nous faire tous les deux
merci Jean-Pierre qui veut répondre à un
rapporteur je vais commencer puis on va
se compléter actuellement
juste sur la question des normes
finalement on a commencé à vider la
baignoire mais elle a continué à se
remplir très rapidement donc c'est à
dire que en réalité voilà le flux de
norme est incessant et le chantier de
simplification lui c'est quelque part
arrêté en tout cas dans son ambition
macro et voilà de volonté d'y aller très
fort et donc ça c'est bien dommage
puisque il existe encore de nombreux
freins malgré le fait qu'il y a
aujourd'hui 2,3 millions de travailleurs
indépendants et puis 3 millions
d'entrepreneurs en France donc ce qui
est quand même une population très
importante même si on regarde les ratios
par rapport à la population active en
France c'est un peu moindre que dans les
autres pays européens puisqu'on est
environ 12% de la population active pour
ce qui est des entrepreneurs mais c'est
c'est un une vraie problématique que ce
flux de norme incessant qui s'ajoute
regardez par exemple maintenant avec la
question qui est très importante de
l'écologie et donc de la transition
énergétique voilà mais on voit aussi
toutes les nouvelles lois qui ont été
adoptées et qui dans leur mise en oeuvre
parfois et bien sont les citoyens sont
confrontés à une complexité on le voit
par exemple sur les applications il y a
ma prime rénov ou c'est le parcours du
combattant pour pour réussir à savoir si
vraiment on y a droit et finalement et
même pour l'avoir donc il y a quand même
beaucoup de sujets de ce type qui sont
voilà donc ça mérite effectivement une
vraie ambition à la fois pour les
citoyens et pour les entrepreneurs donc
de continuer d'amplifier la dynamique et
puis moi dans ce que je vois je trouve
que le
associé les citoyens c'est très
important il y a service public plus par
exemple qui a été lancé qui est une
initiative intéressante puisque
finalement je peux signaler
une difficulté avec une administration
une problématique après c'est pas
suffisamment connu et c'est pas surtout
les sites de l'administration de manière
très visible vous voyez il y a pléthore
d'ailleurs de site on a du mal de
toujours à s'y retrouver et je pense que
une des difficultés que nous n'avons pas
traité et qui reste quand même très
premiante en France c'est qu'il y a donc
les normes globale sur les
réglementations qui protègent un certain
nombre d'activités mais il y a les
réglementations métier
je rappelle par exemple on avait
supprimé la l'obligation faite à un
boulanger de faire une déclaration
administrative en préfecture pour
déclarer ses congés ça existait mais
quand on regarde et quand on va dans le
détail des choses et que l'on regarde
les réglementations métier c'est très
complexe parce que dans le chantier qui
était mené pour entreprendre pour un
service irrépublique.fr nous avons
réussi à unifier l'ensemble des
informations sur la création
d'entreprise la gestion est transmission
des entreprises mais on n'a pas encore
réussi à descendre sur la finesse
vraiment dans le détail de toutes les
réglementations qui existent déjà pour
que si demain je veux créer une activité
dans tel secteur je sache à qui
m'adresser parce que parfois il faut que
je m'adresse à trois administrations
différentes prenons un exemple je
m'arrêterai là je veux créer un
organisme de formation je demandais à la
dritz Une un numéro de comment dire
d'organismes de formation premièrement
mais je dois aussi qu'elle lui piser
mon organisme de formation donc il y a
des délais compressible ce qui fait
qu'entre le moment où je crée mon
activité et le moment réel où je vais
pouvoir vraiment développer un chiffre
d'affaires il peut s'écouler des mois et
des mois vous voyez donc certes il faut
des protections certes bien sûr il faut
de la qualité et en même temps il faut
de la simplicité et un des problèmes que
nous avons c'est qu'on fait non pas
confiance a priori c'est que nous sommes
dans un système de défiance donc comme
nous sommes dans un système de défiance
on veut tout vérifier en amont si vous
voulez avant de lancer quoi que ce soit
alors qu'on devrait laisser justement
les entrepreneurs lancer des initiatives
et des innovations et bien sûr contrôler
postériori je me rappelle on avait
comparé entre la France et l'Allemagne
le fait de pouvoir créer un magasin dans
un dans un centre commercial
ça pouvait se faire en gros en un mois
dans un centre commercial en Allemagne
il fallait six mois en France parce que
il faut toutes les déclarations
administratives préalables pour y
arriver alors que si on fait confiance a
priori vous lancez votre activité et
puis on vient vérifier si vous respectez
le droit par contre si vous ne respectez
pas la règle alors que vous la
connaissez bon ben là on vous sanctionne
oui voilà
trois trois questions donc depuis 2017
il y a des choses intéressantes il y a
trois textes qui ont fait quelques
avancées en matière de simplification
ézoc
et puis le dernier ASAP mais
point précédent
ça passe sous les radars de fait parce
que comme c'est pas évalué les gars
personne n'évalue de manière objective
les gains qu'on peut être les évolutions
sur les sœurs qu'on peut représenter le
droit à l'erreur donc ces souvenirs
alors et donc le bénéfice politique
alors qu'il a eu les coûts politiques
sur les seuils ça a quand même ça
Tanguay on est d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord c'est normal c'est le débat
démocratique donc
tout ce que je vous dis là c'est pour
plaidoyer sur l'outil indépendant vous
avez bien deux sur
les stocks les flux
faut commencer par les stocks on s'est
trompé
mais ça c'est normal dans une politique
publique dans les boissons le public il
faut protéiper une politique publique il
faut l'essayer puis c'est avec le temps
qu'on se rencontre il faut commencer par
les stocks si on change la façon de
fabriquer la loi un petit peu
ce sera beaucoup plus facile de régler
toutes les aberrations qu'il y a dans
les stocks de faut commencer par les
flux pardon c'est pas par les flux
excusez-moi pas les nouvelles les
nouveautés sera beaucoup plus facile de
de d'y aller à la hache sur les anciens
textes pour y arriver il faudrait
l'idéal serait que les études d'impact
soit des vraies études d'impact bon
courage
on y arrivera mais pourquoi normalement
si vous avez votre soutien indépendant
qui est saisi avant toute réglementation
nouvelle pourtant ayant un impact sur la
vie économique du pays et qui à qui vous
demandez un avis vous voyez un simple
avis qui figure en annexe de l'étude
d'impact pour changer tout c'est ce
qu'on appelle la stratégie virale de
réforme de l'action publique vous mettez
un tout petit grain votre conseil il
fait nous on a regardé la question des
panneaux photovoltaïques sur les
parkings de supermarché mais il nous
semble l'intention du 17 heures elle est
bonne parce qu'il veut des recettes mais
il nous semble que il faut être plus
souple que ça peut-être que si un
supermarché veut le faire sur son toit
et pas sur son parking il a qu'à le
faire sur le toit et pas sur le
ça change rien à l'intention du
législateur vous respectez totalement la
décision politique mais vous passez
d'une recette
un mode d'emploi
et tout le problème de l'action publique
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il est trop du côté
de la recette miracle et pas assez du
mode d'emploi je prends un autre exemple
tout bête tout ça c'est l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui et bien sûr de demain les
élèves ça sera pas pourquoi parce que on
va prendre un exemple tout bête les
marchés
doivent changer leur camion c'est 40000
euros un camion pour mettre un camion
électrique il doit mettre des bornes de
recharge ces 15000 euros la borne à 356
c'est rapide donc il en faut 15 ou 20
par mâcher personne peut payer ça tout
ça donc ça sera pas mais en même temps
ça part d'une bonne intention donc là
c'est pareil avec ces effets induits de
la décision donc ça c'est le deuxième
point et si cette méthodologie là vous
la faites sur les stocks elle vous sert
et sur les flux pardon elle vous sert
sur les stocks troisième point sur la
transposition la surtension c'est
exactement pareil alors la noisette je
connaissais pas mais on peut en prendre
à des milliards mais moi je vais vous en
prendre une énorme
qui vient dans l'année ou dans les deux
ans qui vient énorme et montez vite
votre outil c'est DMA DSA le règlement
des données européennes alors là c'est
fantastique c'est il y a deux régimes
ces lois créent de régime je rentre pas
dans le détail parce que je suis tout le
monde n'est pas forcément mais très deux
régimes un régime pour les très très
gros Amazon pas toutes les grosses
plateformes qui seront régis par des
règles européennes et un régime pour des
plus petits c'est discount par exemple
au hasard qui sont régis par des règles
nationales
le ministre qui est sur mon plein de
bonnes intentions l'autre jour a fait
une déclaration en disant mais ce texte
est super parce que il encadre l'usage
qui peut être fait des données les
données nécessaires pour informer le
consommateur ainsi de suite et peut-être
qu'il faudra qu'on aille plus loin que
ce qu'a décidé l'Europe il y a aucun
problème c'est lui qui l'a dit moi j'ai
couru dans son bureau pour lui dire non
surtout fait pas ça parce que là tu tues
c'est discount et tu renforces Amazon si
vous avez votre outil 100 drames sans
rien ils veulent dire il va le dire il
s'agit pas de faire de la polémique
poétique au moment où le texte arrivera
dans l'assemblée et donc il faut élargir
l'objet du texte à des avis sur des
normes françaises mais aussi sur la
transmission il dira attention si vous
surprenez voilà très concrètement les
les conséquences que ça ce qui veut dire
que donc il faut seul pas seulement un
outil mais il faut un outil et quelques
moyens financiers c'est pour ça je
parlais de France stratégie tout à
l'heure parce que on te fera stratégie
le plan il y a quand même beaucoup de
gens beaucoup d'argent qui réfléchissent
au très long terme ce qui est très utile
mais enfin les univers ités ou les
grandes écoles font ça très bien
si on en prenait aller 10% de ces moyens
là pour les mettre sur la simplification
je peux vous assurer que vous changer
radicalement la définition de des
politiques publiques en France
merci donc je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier de vous propose et puis de
d'avoir gardé
à travers la façon de rouler votre
enthousiasme sur le sujet
dans dans vos introductions et la suite
vous avez partiellement ou répondu à des
questions que je voulais vous poser mais
cela dit
Monsieur Mandon vous avez dit que vous
aviez vous avez fait un rapport en 2013
et le sujet était pas d'aujourd'hui mais
en écoutant des représentants du Conseil
d'État j'ai compris que c'était déjà
très ancien puisque
Montaigne oui c'est ça Montaigne avait
déjà soulevé le problème
je sais qu'à l'époque on se plaignait
déjà la jeunesse
cela dit vous avez vous avez écrit en
2013 le Conseil d'État fait un rapport
en 2016 le Conseil d'État proposait de
définir une méthode de calcul de charge
administrative et des autres coups
induits pour toute nouvelle norme a
priori
on donne le dire on y est pas parvenu
alors d'autres pays parviennent donc ma
question si vous voulez c'est d'essayer
de comprendre pourquoi où sont les
blocages et comment on peut quelque part
débloquer parce qu'on peut écrire des
rapports en refaire un autre mais si une
fois qu'on a écrit la partition n'arrive
pas à mettre en musique et à jouer la
musique
on va pas on va pas avancer il y a dans
votre rapport vous avez puisque vous
avez parlé du guichet unique je vais
faire un lien avec a été écrit dans le
rapport de Thierry Mandon engager les
parties prenantes dans un même projet
partagé une stratégie de
progrès gagnant-gagnant est-ce que vous
croyez que dans le guichet unique on a
suivi cette logique qui était proposée
que les usagers qui sont en l'occurrence
là des entrepreneurs ont été vraiment à
associer et si c'est le cas s'il y a mal
pris ici c'est pas le cas pourquoi on
l'a pas fait et il y a un autre point
que le rapport disait c'est la démarche
considère avec la démarche de
simplification est au cœur de du
processus de modernisation de l'action
publique et particulièrement la réforme
de l'État alors vous avez cité des
exemples est-ce que aujourd'hui c'est
véritablement au cœur
je suis très gêné parce que je suis pas
venu
porter un regard critique sur l'action
qui est mené aujourd'hui par le
président et le gouvernement c'est pas
mon propos
mais je pense qu'il y a une opportunité
pour enfin passer à l'âge adulte alors
il faut d'abord il faut l'engagement du
Président on passera compter des
histoires ça marche comme ça en France à
la fin de la fin tout est décidé par le
Conseil des ministres et les deux
personnes qui sont derrière le président
de la République le secrétaire général
du gouvernement de secrétaire général de
l'Élysée toute l'administration
française est organisée en attendant
cette messe hebdomadaire le directeur de
la Jeunesse et des Sports de la région
Limousin va être nommée en conseil des
ministres pour imaginer les choses plus
sain mais donc il faut que le président
s'y mette mais je pense qu'il y a une
opportunité j'en disais un mot tout à
l'heure
il y avait un retard français en matière
de fiscalité pesant sur les entreprises
il
a été corrigé en tout cas en partie
c'est pas contestable c'est cinq
dernières années on peut être d'accord
on peut être contre mais c'est la
différentielle existe encore mais il est
moindre et donc les marges de
renforcement de la compétitivité de
l'industrie française et de l'économie
française par la baisse des impôts
pesant sur les entreprises
c'est limité
si on regarde devant nous ce qui n'est
pas le cas il y a 10 ans
c'est limité les exonérations de charges
sociales là aussi il y a eu énormément
de choses faites de 2012 aujourd'hui
donc les marges de renforcement de la
compétitivité par la baisse des coûts
fiscaux
les charges fiscales de l'impôt dites
vous voulez c'est limité en revanche la
simplification les coûts de la
réglementation
et les économies compères c'est
considérable et c'est comme ça qu'il
faut prendre les choses pour créer ce
changement culturel pour qu'enfin ces
sujets deviennent sérieux vous ouvrez le
Parisien du matin
c'est un sujet qu'on avait vu nous il y
a 10 ans parisien du matin les gars il
fait des minéraux
il va aller faire extraordinaire pour le
cerveau enfin bon bref des progrès il va
les faire agréer sa technologie aux
États-Unis parce qu'en trois mois elle
va être agréée et il pourra produire aux
États-Unis et exporter en France
parce qu'il faut deux ans pour que ce
soit agréé en France et c'est la même
chose c'est pas là je parle mais c'est
la même chose sur énormément de de de de
produits par exemple de santé moi je me
suis intéressé beaucoup aux biotech où
les gens vont en Allemagne produisent en
Allemagne et réimportent en France
donc ça tout ça c'est des coûts
considérable tout ça parce que la
législation il n'y a pas de raison que
on soit trois à quatre fois plus long en
France qu'en Allemagne pour agréer des
médicaments c'est à dire que ce serait
tel ou tel République je sais pas où
mais ça n'a aucun sens
je sais pas la noisette les dépôts les
dépôts agricoles le stockage les lieux
de stockage deux ans en France six mois
maximum en Allemagne ça n'a pas de sens
donc il y a énormément de gains pour
l'économie donc il faut utiliser cette
situation nouvelle des possibilités
d'évolution fiscale de renforcement de
la compétitivité par le réseau des
impôts ou pas limiter en revanche des
gains considérés et je crois que là on
peut sur l'entreprise moins au point que
mon ami Laurent grandir
donc sur la question des du guichet
unique d'entreprise le problème qui a eu
c'est qu'ils ont confondu
le back-office et le front office
c'est-à-dire en gros ils ont confondu le
guichet unique qui est l'entité qui
permet d'enregistrer une demande et de
la traiter d'accord et la communication
l'information faite aux entrepreneurs et
donc les deux étaient entremêlés et donc
quand on m'a appelé dernière pour
essayer de déminer un peu le sujet j'ai
dit il faut d'abord on va traiter la
question de l'information d'entrepreneur
par une pépite française qui est service
public.fr quand même qui est le site le
plus visité en France et il y aura donc
créé un nouveau truc parce que ça existe
déjà et on va créer donc un espace
spécifique pour les entrepreneurs et
donc ça a été très développé très vite
et on a associé les entrepreneurs on les
interrogeant à travers des enquêtes des
questionnaires des entretiens et on a
fait ça en deux mois on a tous ce
travail d'enquête et d'associations des
entrepreneurs et on a réussi à l'époque
à interrogé plus de 600 entrepreneurs
qui ont répondu en deux mois donc ça a
été très rapide intense parce que le
temps était contraint le guichet unique
c'est à dire le traitement qui s'est
fait là on était en quoi c'est à dire
dans quoi Monsieur Merlin qui a fait un
très très gros travail très intéressant
mais infini qu'elle était la raison
c'est à dire bon il y a les greffiers il
va falloir qu'on m'intégrer de côté et
puis on va distribuer les greffiers
parce que c'est un système entre
guillemets corporatiste etc d'accord
donc c'est des systèmes qui se sont
finalement opposés et qui n'ont pas été
entremêlés la difficulté elle est là à
mon avis et d'ailleurs ça ne fonctionne
pas puisque là aujourd'hui au moment où
je parle il y a plein de
dysfonctionnements sur ce guichet unique
parce que quand vous quand vous bâtissez
un système finalement contre un autre
système plutôt que de dire comment on
fait ensemble en reprenant l'histoire la
culture du système je veux dire il faut
pas effacer la culture et l'histoire
elle est là donc bâtissons de cette
façon et je pense que la méthodologie
qui a été employée donc n'a pas été la
bonne et donc c'est un sujet mais qui
est une arlésienne finalement parce que
qu'à la fin vous avez le guichet unique
du guichet unique et on en créé tous les
jours et puis vous vous retrouvez
plusieurs guichets uniques à la fin vous
c'est comme les maisons il y a des
maisons dans tous les domaines donc je
pense que vraiment cette méthodologie du
guichet unique malgré le très bon
travail qui a été fait par Monsieur
Merlin
dysfonctionne parce que il y a cette on
a mélangé le koal comment vous voyez
dans ce dans encore une fois dans cette
histoire il faut se donner des cibles on
se dit voilà la priorité c'est la
simplification par exemple des démarches
d'entreprise et il faut une seule entrée
très bien mais après les son faire les
acteurs voilà dans et avec les
usagers les entrepreneurs peu importe le
service public pour construire la
solution et de faire de manière très
pragmatique il faut être pragmatique et
ne pas mélanger toujours ces deux voilà
parce qu'on a je pense qu'on a voulu
voilà traiter un autre sujet que celui
vraiment du guichet unique
merci on va devoir conclure je suis
désolé pour mes collègues mais on a fait
un vaste tour d'horizon passionnant
évidemment
il faudra compléter peut-être par le
questionnaire simplifié qu'on vous a
adressé et puis monsieur ministre ce
tournoi vers vous parce que vous avez
proposé certains documents qu'on a
peut-être pas et qui seront intéressants
pour enrichir notre propos
d'accord
je suis désolé d'accélérer cette fin de
réunion mais vous savez qu'à 10h30 on
reprend
non pas un texte soit simplification
mais un texte complexe sur les retraites
et donc il faut il faut vraiment
rejoindre les Mexique en tout cas merci
tous les deux monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président vraiment en ayant
chanté d'avoir entendu vos propos et ça
va enrichir largement notre réflexion
bonne journée à vous
[Musique]